[Musique]
les canadiens iront donc aux urnes le 20
septembre
nous on ne règlera chaque décision qu'on
ne fait rien on va continuer à
développer des graisses solution
les canadiens mais je me ferai les deux
ensemble on va agir à l'avenir
faut toujours avoir un plein et fingers
le bloc a reproché
[Applaudissements]
l'important c'est de mettre de l'avant
ce qui sera bon pour
[Musique]
devenir le prochain premier pour aider
les gens une société plus juste et plus
égalitaire
mon job c'est de gagner des sièges
notre attention doit être ciblée sur a
les solutions vous avez un choix de 7e
l'action blé afin pas repris mais deux
choix le choix voire partenaires au
développement cette aux canadiens de
décider et canadiens méritent d'avoir
leur mot à dire en direct du musée
canadien de l'histoire à gatineau le
groupe de diffusion des débats vous
présente le débat des chefs
voici patrice pelât
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs bienvenue
au débat des chefs nous sommes donc au
musée canadien de l'histoire à gatineau
plus précisément dans la grande galerie
qui a été vous le voyez transformé en
studio télévision au cours des derniers
jours ce débat est largement diffusée
par plusieurs partenaires traduit et
relayée également dans plusieurs langues
et je lève mon chapeau déjà aux
interprètes que je rencontrais derrière
bonne chance parce que débat c'est pas
évident à traduire en temps réel bravo
la place des chefs et l'ordre de parole
ont évidemment été déterminé au hasard
mais surtout le bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
trudeau bonsoir bonsoir pas très madame
paule bonsoir bonsoir monsieur singh
bonsoir bonsoir ce blanchet bon soit
bien avant tout le monde merci d'être là
très sincèrement c'est un exercice sain
est vraiment précieux en démocratie ou
l'oublient parfois ici cinq thèmes
seront abordés ce soir chaque thème sera
lancé par une question d'un citoyen non
aimé mercier bonsoir on a reçu de très
bonnes que oui à peu près mille
questions des questions senti pertinente
intelligente qui nous ont beaucoup
inspiré tout au long de la préparation
du débat de ce soir on a hâte d'entendre
ça il y aura des confrontations à 2 puis
à 3 les rats des questions en rafale de
nos journalistes invités
chaque bloc va se terminer par un débat
le plus libre possible
on vise évidemment un temps de parole
équitable entre tous les chefs avant de
commencer le premier dès le premier
thème je pose une première question à
tous les chefs et vous aurez 45 secondes
plus tôt que la déclaration d'ouverture
therez 45 secondes pour répondre c'est
une élection je pense qu'on peut
s'entendre pardonnez moi mais ce trou
d'eau mais c'est une élection non
désirées ça c'est le passé mais je veux
vous amener vers le futur vous engagez
vous si vous gagnez un gouvernement
minoritaire à ne pas déclencher
d'élections précipitées à respecter
votre mandat de 4 à goethe rude
autrement dit vous n'allez pas nous
faire le même coup de voile sur trudeau
première réponse 45 seulement merci
patrice je veux d'abord remercier les
canadiens d'un bout à l'autre de ce pays
d'être ici ce soir avec nous mais aussi
pour tout le travail que vous avez fait
pendant sept ans et demi pour qu'on
passe à travers qu'on continue à ce à
travers je veux m'attarder sur
l'expression que patrice a utilisé une
élection non désirées vous allez
entendre ce soir à des perspectives et
des approches radicalement différentes
sur comment on doit en finir avec la
pandémie comment on va rebâtir en mieux
et vous méritez d'avoir le choix parce
que le gouvernement que vous élisez va
prendre ses décisions maintenant cet
automne pendant un an pendant deux ans
sur les changements climatiques sur la
vaccination sur les armes à feu vous
avez le choix importants à faire est
moins chère de continuer à travailler
avec vous on va y revenir merci monsieur
trudeau la question je vous le rappelle
mais surtout le c est ce que vous
engagez souge est élue à la tête d'un
gouvernement minoritaire de ne pas
déclencher d'élections avant quatre ans
oui absolument on doit travailler
ensemble contre la pandémie contre les
défis devant nous après le pont demi ce
n'est pas le temps pour une élection
mais on doit voir plein pour le futur
comme vous avez dit monsieur roy pour le
futur et au début de la quarantaine on a
lancé notre plan pour le rétablissement
du canada le plein avec cinq piliers les
emplois une loi anti corps option
leadership sur la santé mentale des
canadiens un prêt d'être plus près dans
le futur pour les futures pandémies un
plan dit qu'il est prêt le budget parce
que après six ans de monsieur du dos on
a beaucoup de dettes et aucune
opportunité pour nos jeunes qui est ce
qu'elle est absolument du début de votre
réponse est absolument je ne
déclencherait pas moi même des élections
on doit travailler ensemble sur la
relance économique et la pandémie très
bien monsieur singh 45 secondes oui
merci merci beaucoup très bien moins
grande un bonjour tout le monde je veux
dire clairement que on n'a pas vu lui
d'avoir cette élection parce que on veut
travailler on semble donc je m'engage de
respecter le mandat des canadiens
canadien et votre voix ce que vous allez
choisir parce que vous avez le choix
important dans cette élection vous avez
le choix d'un autre carton de monsieur
trudeau qui a laissé les grands risques
d'exploiter le système ou de choisir
l'un [ __ ] qui vont dire clairement ce sont
les milliardaires qui doit payer leur
juste part pour investir dans l'avenir
pour les gens pour faire face à la crise
climatique pour investir dans nos soins
de santé et pour dire clairement qu'on
va régler la crise dudelange bon aussi
donc vous avez le choix je vous
encourage choisir un [ __ ] je suis
blanche est ce que j'allais tout faire
pour garder en vie le prochain
gouvernement quel qu'il soit c'est ça
l'esprit de la question oui en effet
pour moi qui prendrai la décision
cependant
je pense qu'un gouvernement doit
s'organiser lorsqu'il est minoritaire
pour aller chercher l'appui de
suffisamment de députés dans un
parlement pour rester en poste c'est
l'esprit de la loi sur les élections à
date fixe je constate avec soulagement
que le premier ministre qui disait qu'on
se retrouverait un élections dans 18
mois veut maintenant faire son mandat au
complet je m'étonne par contre qu'il
n'ait pas pu déposer sa place sa propre
plateforme électorale avant plus de deux
semaines après le déclenchement de
l'élection qu'il avait lui même
déclenché pour le bloc on gardera la
même philosophie si c'est bon pour le
québec on votre pour si c'est mauvais
pour le québec on votera contre mais
comme on le fait de nombreuses fois on
améliore ce sur quoi on vote pour que ça
serve le québec on va revenir on va
revenir en détail avec toutes ces
questions mais madame paule à la même
question est ce que vous feriez tout
pour garder un gouvernement en vie le
plus longtemps possible
d'abord c'est un honneur d'adressé sur
les territoires n'ont cédé des
algonquins megache et oui absolument a
malheureusement en conséquence adua
promesses à briser de monsieur trudeau
et son gouvernement nous nous sommes
dans notre système actuel il faut
trouver des manières de travailler
ensemble en collaboration et coopération
à le fait que nous sommes dans une
élection est une est une symptômes une
conséquence de le fait qu'on ne cherche
pas de travail ensemble en charge de
travail de manière hyper partisans et je
dis que les gens il veut il ne veut pas
être consulté sur l'écran on termine à
la pandémie il veut que ça termine et on
travaille ensemble pour le faire merci
beaucoup je très disciplinés en tout cas
ça commence bien pour ça merci
[Musique]
premier thème incontournable évidemment
la pandémie et la santé noémie une
première question du public mais on en a
reçu beaucoup beaucoup sur ce thème je
vous rappelle que plus de 27000
personnes sont mortes des suites de
lakovic 19 au canada et 2 ce nombre au
moins la moitié sont décédées dans des
résidences pour personnes âgées souvent
dans la solitude parfois dans des
conditions atroces on s'en souvient et
notre première citoyenne a invité
s'appelle bernadette landry on va aller
la retrouver à dieppe au nouveau
brunswick bonsoir madame landry
bonsoir merci beaucoup de vous joindre à
nous et de briser la glace ce soir alors
vous vous appliquez dans une association
au nouveau brunswick qui défend les
droits des aînés et où il ya quelque
chose que vous aimeriez demandé au chef
allez-y on vous écoute
oui la pandémie nous a ouvert les yeux
sur
la négligence et la maltraitance des
aînés qui sont en perte d'autonomie des
personnes vulnérables et istres camp
jusqu'ici les gouvernements provinciaux
n'ont pas l'air de faire grand chose
pour
empêcher que ça continue tout ça parce
que ça continue c'est là avant et ça
continue alors si vous devenu premier
ministre qu'est ce que vous allez faire
pour vous assurer que les gouvernements
provinciaux
protège mieux les ennemis qui sont en
perte d'autonomie et qu'on arrête de les
négliger et de les maltraiter merci
beaucoup madame landry je vous confirme
que les chefs ont écouté attentivement
votre question voyons ce qui vont vous
répondre mais c'est au tour où l'on
commence avec vous vous avez 45 secondes
merci pour la question bernadette on va
avoir une approche claire sur la santé
des canadiens et des québécois pour nos
aînés on va augmenter les transferts en
santé dans une année à stable prévisible
et sans conditions et avec une monte à
près de 60 milliards de dollars on doit
travailler ensemble sur notre système
public et universel et petits quidams
ans après la pandémie on doit apprendre
les laissant on doit travailler ensemble
sur les résidences pour aînés les ch et
celle des au québec c'est pour on a une
forme de trois milliards de dollars pour
des investissements dans les seychelles
des dans les résidences pour aînés je
vais respecter les chambres des
compétences mais on doit travailler
ensemble merci monsieur autour madame
paule à vous la parole
mon père est mort dans un centre de
soins de longue durée dont la deuxième
vague de la pandémie et je n'oublierai
jamais ça je n'oublierai pas à tous les
milliers de personnes qui ont perdu
leurs proches et nous sommes
malheureusement en train de l'oublier il
faut avoir une approche radicale une
réforme radicale de notre système il
faut avoir des standards nationale il
faut avoir en faut il faut voir que
notre système devient partie de notre
loi canadienne sur la santé parce que
c'est les choses qu'on protège son don
ce loi il faut assurer une minimum à de
soins pour nos aînés nous n'avons pas
voté pour le discours du trône
précisément parce qu'il n'avait pas un
plan pour nos aînés merci madame
monsieur blanchet nam landry dit les
gouvernements provinciaux ne suffisent
pas à la tâche on ne peut pas compter
sur eux qu'est ce que vous lui répondez
c'est très désolant comme constat ce que
madame landry nous dit parce que ça
reflète une perception la priorité des
systèmes de santé des provinces et de
donner des soins rouge et pour le faire
il leur faut les moyens or la
contribution fédérale à chacune des
provinces qui unanimement demandent une
augmentation des transferts de l'argent
qu'ils voient pour les soins pour les
gens pour la réduction des les attend ce
pour du personnel en santé le fédéral
des libéraux avec une intention
similaire chez les autres partis c'est
de retenir cet argent sous réserve
d'imposer des conditions fédéral avec la
prétention que le fédéral connaissons
mieux que les provinces alors que la
solution efficace c'est de confier
l'argent à ceux qui ont déjà une
expertise merci monsieur blanchet
monsieur singh merci beaucoup
premièrement un grand merci madame
landry pour la question et c'est
vraiment une honte nationale s'est passé
dans cette pandémie ne fait que deux
aînés étaient les plus frappés simplisme
et vous avez raison on doit aider les
gens pour moi je ne peux pas rester les
bras croisés quand je vois les gens qui
souffrent oui je respect des
juridictions mais je vais aider je
cherche des solutions je pense que les
deux c'est quelqu'un qui cherche des
solutions park parc à ces personnes qui
cherchent des excuses donc ce qu'on veut
faire c'est d enlever les profits dans
les centres de soins de longue durée
pour les des légions on veut avoir plus
d'appuis pour les jeunes pour que les
puits de les gens puissent rester chez
eux mais monsieur trudeau et mais
surtout ils ont voté contre cette idée
de devenir officier merci monsieur
trudeau pour clore cette premier tour de
table merci madame landry pour votre
question je suis comme vous comme des
millions de canadiens on a regardé avec
horreur ce qui s'est passé pendant ces
pandémies à nos aînés les plus
vulnérables d'un bout à l'autre de ce
pays c'est pas juste dans un endroit au
nouveau-brunswick c'était partout et
nous devons faire mieux oui le fédéral a
envoyé des soldats à des militaires pour
aider mais nous devons apprendre et
constaté que la situation nos aînés
c'est pas juste pendant la pandémie
qu'elle était assez piètre ça fait
longtemps que c'est la réalité donc le
fédéral qui respecte les compétences des
provinces un rôle à jouer pour assurer
les résultats on propose d'embaucher
50000 préposés aux bénéficiaires de plus
et d'assurer 25 $ par leur parce que les
conditions de travail c'est les
conditions de soins et on va être là
pour toujours si monsieur trudeau alors
madame landry on a pu vous voir réagir
pendant les réponses des chefs est ce
que ça vous satisfait
oui merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
participé à voir bon c'est encourageant
merci madame landry on va y revenir dans
le débat ouvert à 5 d'ailleurs sur ces
questions de santé des sièges celle des
du rôle du fédéral des provinces mais
d'abord confrontation à 2 madame paule
monsieur singh je veux parler de
vaccination madame paule ce n'est pas
clair si vous êtes contre la vaccination
obligatoire il ya deux semaines j'ai pas
totalement compris votre réponse vous
pourrez éclaircir monsieur si vous êtes
résolument pour la vaccination
obligatoire
vous n'avez pas peur que ça en flammes
encore plus les manifestants et ceux qui
ne veulent pas se faire vacciner et
concret deux mondes au canada
est drôlement triste de voir la
politisation de notre d'un enjeu à qui
est en jeu a de
notre santé publique ah oui absolument
nous sommes en faveur que chaque
personne qui peut être d'actionner qui
est capable d'être vaccinées soit
d'actionner je crois que tous les partis
où ils ont je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ça je suis tout à fait d'accord
mais demeure posée c'est exactement ce
qu'on doit faire on doit aider les gens
un des traits vacciner on doit avoir
plus d rhésus pour les aider je ne veux
pas diviser la population ce que je veux
faire c'est des produits protéger la
population messi aussi pourquoi je veux
revenir à la question de madame landry
ce qui s'est passé dans les centres de
soins de longue durée comme madame par
l'adie été horrible mais ce qu'on a
appris c'était dans les centres de soins
de landry durée à biaudos créative on a
vu des pires conditions donc pour moi la
question c'est pourquoi monsieur trudeau
et messieurs o'toole on monte pour les
services privés it is aziez c'est
complètement le gym est retourné à la
vaccination
retournez à la vaccination si je voulais
je voulais juste dire que c'était eux
moitié de ma la réponse je voulais dire
que c'est très clair que nous aurons a
besoin les accrocs mais deux autres
mandats sion pour les gens qui ne peut
pas être vaccinés il est à des tests de
dépistage rapide il y à d autres options
et on sait très bien chaque à qui on
doit les utiliser alors d'utiliser
quelque chose qui devraient être guidées
par le sillon scarano noam les habits de
données sur c est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec le mouvement du québec qui
a dit les récalcitrants mais il reste à
la maison non payés ils rallieront pas
de salaire est-ce que vous gérez jusque
là je dis je dis que oui on doit avoir
des conséquences mais on doit faire tout
ce qu'on peut pour aider les gens data
vacciner on peut trouver d autres moyens
d'aider les gens à et les gens qui ne
peut pas le faire on peut trouver les
autres solutions je vous laisse je veux
savoir quelles sont ses conséquences
parce que si on peut nous rassurer être
d'accord c'est beaucoup mieux que d'être
aussi pour ça que je posais qu'elles
sont mais j'essaye de voir parce que des
nuances dans chacun des fois les gens ne
s'y retrouvent pas maintenant droit de
parole monsieur blanchet monsieur
trudeau monsieur o'toole sur trudeau on
vous a vu entouré de manifestants depuis
le début de la campagne
je vous pose la même question ce cri
n'est pas en train de se créer au canada
dans un cercle vicieux et plus vous
obligez les gens de faire vacciner plus
à des manifestants el-assad on a
effectivement politiser cette question
mais c'est un faux débat patrice il n'y
a plus de débat sur la vaccination comme
étant la façon qu'on va s'en sortir
c'est exactement ce que la science nos
mères chercheurs nous dit et je fais une
distinction entre cette meute qui est en
train de manifester et ceux qui pour des
raisons personnelles sont encore
hésitants à se faire vacciner il faut
oui les informer mais il faut aussi
les démontrer que c'est dans leur
intérêt de se faire vacciner pourront
pas prendre un train un avion pourront
pas travailler pour la fonction publique
fédérale et avec des passeports
vaccinale qu'on va payer pour les
provinces ils pourront pas aller au
resto au jam à au théâtre oui c'est
important de dire clairement ça passe
par la vaccination presque 80 % des
canadiens au fait leur job vérité encore
hymne à la nature tout va changer la vie
là dessus vous jette contre une
vaccination obligatoire les vaccins sont
pré mondial
les vaccins sont sécuritaires et
efficaces et j'encourage tous les
canadiens tous les québécois se faire
vacciner mais en plein d'un band mais ce
n'est pas le temps d'avoir une proche de
division on doit travailler ensemble
chaque palier de gouvernement on doit
utiliser tous les outils les vaccins les
tester dépistage rapide quotidienne les
masques la distanciation sociale mais en
pleine d'une pandémie pourquoi est ce
que mr to do à déclencher une élection
on doit travailler contre la quatrième
vague park sur le lot d'aventurés au
tour fait une équivalence entre la
vaccination et lettres stage et c'est
pas du tout la même chose quand tu te
fais testé positif je l'avais
allégations mais surtout avec le virus
en demi pourquoi on doit cibler ce
quartier j'ai canadien on doit lutter
ensemble contre la corvette 19 avec une
approche de dilma poser une question
directe pourquoi cette élection pendant
la pandémie justement parce qu'il ya des
décisions très importantes à prendre sur
comment on va en finir moi je crois à
exiger de la vaccination convaincre un
par un avion monsieur o'toole veux pas
faire ça c'est un choix clair puis les
canadiens devraient avoir leur possible
en chirurgie de matane oui dans un
premier temps
quand j'étais jeune en termes plus crus
le monsieur du dépendant pas loin de
chez nous disait essentiellement
j'aurais pas mis le feu mais je leur ai
pas été j'étais pas mal plus directe
qu'elle soit c'est un plus ça qu'on est
confronté plutôt que de répondre par de
l'information par de l'éducation par une
incitation à aller tout le monde se
faire vacciner on est dans un espèce de
d'affrontements qui ne sert absolument
fait de surcroît fait je veux prendre
mon droit à la parole vous prendrez le
vôtre quand ce sera le temps de surcroît
les exemples que monsieur trudeau a
donné son tout à part les frontières
dont il s'est pas occupé puis le
transport des juridictions du québec
c'est québec qui va décider poli jim
police à oran pour les écoles et la
contrainte et la conversion des comptes
ronde et n'étaient merci elle n'était
que pur merci ce blanchet vous trois ans
va y revenir dans le débat ouvert à 5 g
comme mes collègues viendront plus tard
j'ai des questions en rafale pour chacun
d'entre vous c'est un mélange entre eux
d une formule ouverte et des questions
en rafale pour que les citoyens puissent
comprendre le fond de votre logique
c'est ça notre objectif madame paule
tout le hasard qui détermine les
nombreux savez madame paule assurance
médicaments assurance dentaire
plus de choix dans les sièges dans les
sièges celle des votre programme dit on
est ambitieux mais pas chiffré comment
peut-on vous prendre au sérieux
le chiffre est il faut aussi dire que
bon ça fait que deux années que nous on
était dans les élections en avait une
une programme complètement chiffré mais
je veux dire que c'est le moment
malheureusement nous sommes dans une
élection c'est le moment d'être
ambitieux je crois que la pandémie a
changé les choses ça bouleversé moi et
ma famille je crois que les gens veut
prendre une différents parcours on ne
veut pas aller sur la même voie si on
veut faire ça on doit dire oui nous
allons avoir l'ambition nous allons être
audacieux nous allons proposer que tout
le monde vivent une vie de dignité au
canada nous avons tout ce qu'il faut
vraiment beaucoup aimé ce n'est pas
chiffré ce dépôt chiffré vous dit pas
encore mais certains parce qu'il reste
du chemin
ça arrive c'était en fait une élection
déclenché à d'étranges radio ser notre
jeu ça arrive monsieur blanchet bon bien
sûr vous en avait parlé il ya les
compétences provinciales les gens sont
très sensibles à seurre notamment au
québec mais pourquoi refuser toute
collaboration avec le fédéral je vous
rappelle que
5718 décès dans les sièges celle des
beaucoup plus qu en ontario une
population plus grande n'y at-il pas
matière à ouverture et modestie devant
ce dossier le raisonnement que vous
suggérez dit que parce que c'était le
système québécois ou parce que c'était
les normes québécois c'est moins bon que
si ça avait été le système où les normes
fédérales or le federer engage pas de
médecin engage pas d'infirmières engage
pour toutes les spécialités en santé le
fédéral au contraire retient de l'argent
depuis longtemps qui s'il avait été mis
en amont dans le système de santé de
toutes les provinces qui le demande tout
il y aurait déjà eu d'emblée un système
de santé plus solides plus efficace plus
robustes pour faire face à la crise
quant à l'explication précise on ne la
connaît pas et moi je me refuse à
utiliser des décès comme argument
politique très bien monsieur o'toole
croyez vous que les canadiens devraient
avoir le choix de payer pour se faire
soigner plus rapidement donc payer pour
se faire soigner plus rapidement non je
vais toujours respecté les chambres des
compétences des provinces et des
décisions
des provinces parce que comme monsieur
blanchet a dit c'est une compétence
provinciale et je vais augmenter les
transferts en santé dans une manière
stable prévisible et sans conditions
parce que c'est une question de respect
et moi je fais confiance au gouvernement
du québec pourquoi est ce que monsieur
to do a toujours ingéré dans les
chambres des compétences
particulièrement après la pandémie après
la triste situation dans le csld on doit
travailler ensemble pour le bien-être
des canadiens des québécois c'est
pourquoi on a un plan pour le
rétablissement du canada et des
investissements historiques dans notre
système de santé peut pas plus de priver
c'est la question dans les soins de
santé
j'appuie notre système public et
universel sur trudeau question toute
simple pour vous combien coûtent les
doses de vaccins en europe il ya des
chiffres qui sont sortis est ce que les
canadiens ne devraient pas savoir son
hub passez moi l'expression mais un bon
deal ou s'est fait avoir ce que les
canadiens ça c'est que on a investi
assez d'argent pour qu'on soit en tête
de lice à dans la planète en termes de
vaccination on a assez de vaccins pour
tout le monde et on est payé des prix
compétitifs pour des raisons de
compétition vous les donnez pas parce
c'est parce que c'est des contrats avec
des compagnies privées mais on va on est
en train de chercher à être le plus
transparent possible mais je veux
revenir sur les deux réponses de mes
collègues monsieur monsieur au tall ne
comprend pas que c'est le rôle du
fédéral de défendre la loi canadienne
sur la santé qui empêche justement le
privé de s'immiscer dans le fédéral dans
les cimes de santé même dans les
provinces il ne se tient pas debout
contre le système à deux vitesses et
monsieur blanchet tu oublies que dans
les forces armées quand sont arrivés au
temps et cherche à s'élever au québec il
y avait des médecins du fédéral qui
étaient là mais non on n'a pas toutes
les réponses on va
avoir le loisir de de parler de tout ça
monsieur singh vous proposez on est
toujours la pandémie vous proposer des
soins dans votre programme de santé
mentale gratuit pour tous ceux
qui ont souffert de la pandémie pidio
ces canaux beaucoup
bravo mais vous prenez ou vos
psychologue il en manque cruellement il
ya 9 110 places il n'y a pas de
psychologues pour les combler au canada
c'était l'enjeu c'est vraiment le
problème est en droit civil et comment
dans cette pandémie on a déjà eu des
problèmes avant de cette pandémie
d'avoir accès aux services de santé
mentale cette situation s'empirer
pendant la pandémie et c'est vraiment
une temps difficiles qui a eu des grands
d'impact sur la santé mentale de
plusieurs personnes de tellement
personnes donc ce qu'on veut faire c'est
de s'assurer que les gens ont accès aux
services essentiels
ça veut dire d'inclure les soins de
santé mentale dans notre soins de santé
je sais que ça va être difficile mais
c'est nécessaire et c'est exactement ce
qu'on va faire
très bien alors le débat ouvert cinq
minutes il est à vous monsieur automne
le hasard a fait que c'est vous qui
commencez le canada vient d'ouvrir ses
frontières pour les doubles vacciner
hier ses frontières internationales est
ce que ça vous inquiète je lance le
débat on doit avoir une frontière
sécuritaire empreinte d'une pandémie
c'est pourquoi on doit utiliser le
niveau de vaccination pour les autres
pays particulièrement les etats-unis
mais aussi on doit utiliser le test de
dépistage rapide quotidien à la
frontière j'ai proposé ça il y a un an
et malheureusement comme d'habitude le
gouvernement de monsieur trudeau était
la seule tests de dépistage rapide lent
avec les vaccins en pleine d'une
pandémie c'est possible d'avoir une
frontière ouverts mais sécuritaire c'est
très important pour la vie rendent tout
d'abord aussi très bien que maintenant
on est en train de voir une quatrième
vague des non vaccinés ceux qui sont
vaccinés qui ont fait leurs devoirs fait
leur part pour la société ne sont pas
une source de risque et on peut en plus
revenir un peu plus à la normale en
accueillant des voyageurs de
l'international qui sont pleinement
vacciner parce que on veut reprendre la
vie normale mais la réalité c'est qu'on
est en train de s'assurer que ce soit
pas un vecteur de transmission ça ne
l'est pas et on veut récompenser ceux
qui ont fait leur devoir et je comprends
pas pourquoi monsieur autour et monsieur
blanchette sont en train d'être flou sur
la vaccination
quelque chose est en train
on est dans un quartier un vague de la
cobi 19 monsieur trudeau c'était la
mauvaise chose à faire de déclencher
l'action quand on sait on est toujours
des défis et particulièrement parce que
la seule raison pour laquelle vous avez
déclenché cette à l'action c'est pour
une raison égoïste d'avoir plus de
pouvoir signer pas une bonne chose à
faire donc tout notre avis on aurait dû
continuer de faire face à cette pandémie
de livrer l'aide aux gens de réaliser
que cette pandémie n'est pas fini on a
plus d enjeu on doit réaliser ça et on
doit agir pourquoi vous avez décroché
c'était la chaussée aucune chance et je
complète d'être d'accord avec monsieur
singh sur ce point ah parceque
on a des options on peut pas mobiliser
les gens qui sont fâchés a qui ne sont
pas d'actionner où on peut essayer de
les éduquer on peut essayer de leur
assemblée on a déjà parlé de les besoins
du santé nos de création des racismes
ans de santé mentale investissements
dans l'eau sèche assure des a beaucoup
d'enjeu amont devraient être au
parlement discuter ces choses on semble
trouver des solutions et trouver de
l'aide dont les gens ont besoin encore
parce que nous sommes encore dans une
pandémie monsieur blanchet là les
frontières sont inquiets tous les fronts
que moi je suis plutôt d'accord sur le
principe à l'effet que la double
vaccination est un standard intéressant
je pense par contre que ça doit être
coordonnée avec les autres pays avec
lesquels le plus des changes qui se font
toutefois avant de parler du flou des
autres je m'arrangerai pour pas avoir
déposé ma plateforme deux semaines en
retard et avoir commencé à la changer
dès le lendemain matin je pense que
c'est moins clair et ce qui est moins
clair aussi c'est la capacité du canada
sous cette administration avoir des
échanges parce que même le président
américain auprès des prêts à parler au
premier ministre du canada aucc ordonné
l'ouverture la principale frontières
pacifique au monde donc il ya des enjeux
qui demande la clarté pas nécessairement
moi le premier mais ne faut répondre
encore une fois cette question
d'élection vous êtes en train de voir
les téléspectateurs sont en train de
voir à quel point il ya des différences
assez profonde dans notre vision sur
comment on va en finir avec la pandémie
et ces élections sont justement la
chance pour les canadiens choisir
monsieur roy vous ne m'avez pas demandé
c'est quoi notre plan pour le système de
santé nous on propose à peu près 25
milliards de dollars d'investissements
dans les médecins de famille agents de
la santé mentale sur les quatre
prochaines années et on voir absolument
le faire dans la
ccfl a exigé des résultats pour
travailler avec les provinces oui mais
on assume nos responsables et les gens
je vais me permettre un oui ou non
rapide rappeler de bons monsieur
blanchet je connais la réponse au besoin
le transfert du droit 28 milliards oui
ou non aller vous à transférer aux profs
mais je vais exiger que ce soit ce que
vous voyez sur ces 4 28 milliards aux
provinces oui ou non il veut augmenter
les transferts en santé oui mais pas
vaincu milliards on veut les
augmentations
on veut les augmenter mes proches madame
paule nous avons à inviter à les
provinces de d'être là sur à la table
avec le gouvernement de province pour
fédéral pour alger pour négocier mais
c'est pas une négociation c'est la
création d'une refonte de votre dos il y
a des lacunes st oui ou non en principe
plus de 25 milliards oui 5 milliards 25
milliards en santé n'ont pas sans
conditions on va travailler avec les
provinces pour l'idée des résultats tout
25 milliards milliards de dollars au
cours de la prochaine décennie sans
conditions parce que c'était une
question de respect ok très bien alors
merci beaucoup premier débat ouvert
[Musique]
coût de la vie et financeurs publics
nous avons une question du public so lu
ment la pénurie de main d'oeuvre et les
criantes et elle coûte cher aux
entreprises elles bouleversent les
collectivités même on va aller rejoindre
quelqu'un qui est affectée par cette
pénurie qui s'appelle marc antoine
poulain on le jouait chez lui à saint
prosper dans chaudière appalaches
bonsoir monsieur poulin
bonjour noémie merci de vous joindre à
nous alors vous vous travaillez pour une
pme de la bosse qui fabrique des
planchers de bois franc et vous avait de
la misère à recruter des travailleurs
alors qu'est ce que vous aimeriez dire
aux chiffres ce soir
en fait tout les secteurs économiques de
la région des problèmes de pénurie de
main d'oeuvre on voit des entreprises
qui doivent rapporter des projets on
voit des entreprises qui doivent parfois
la nature un petit peu leur croissance
par manque de personnel également les
entreprises organismes communautaires
ont le même problème en ayant des
difficultés à recruter du personnel et
peut arriver qu'ils aient de la
difficulté à donner un service à leurs
citoyens ma question pour les chefs est
la suivante quel est le plan de votre
parti pour pallier à cette pénurie de
main d'oeuvre merci beaucoup monsieur
poulin pour cette question alors c'est
très clair qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
contrer la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
monsieur signe à vous la parole merci
j'ai manqué le nombre de familles et
monsieur poulin couru l'arc antoine
poulin merci beaucoup monsieur poulin
pour la question je m'excuse j'ai manqué
le nom mais c'est vraiment grande en jeu
vous avez su élever comment c'est un
enjeu dans votre région vous avez parlé
de comment ça frappe les gens et les
industries les entreprises c'est
vraiment quelque chose à difficile et sa
frappe à travers le pays donc on a
quelques solutions on pense qu'on peut
mieux utiliser notre système
d'immigration pour accueillir des
nouveaux arrivants qui vont aider dans
cette lutte contre la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre on peut aussi aider dans la
et l'éducation pour la formation qui
connecte avec les industries et les
entreprises qui ont besoin d aide donc
ce sont les quelques mesures qu'on peut
prendre merci mais ceci monsieur blanc
lâche qu'est-ce que la proposition pour
vous monsieur poulin la première c'est
la suspension fut-elle temporaire de la
pcr eux parce que ce programme là pour
l'instant retient des gens qui
pourraient aller sur le marché du
travail je garderai une exception pour
les arts est à bien des égards le
tourisme des programmes de crédits
d'impôt plus généreux pour les jeux les
jeunes retraités qui pourrait choisir de
continuer à donner quelques journées par
semaine au marché du travail une
ouverture à l'immigration sous réserve
bien sûr de la capacité d'intégration
vous voulez chez vous des gens qui
seront capables de travailler en
français ça restera un critère
fondamental et un enfant que je
regarderai peut-être davantage c'est de
soutenir le bénévolat qui représente une
force de travail de gens qui ont encore
à donner un système de crédit d'impôt
pourrait peut-être servir en particulier
dans le monde communautaire merci
beaucoup pour cette réponse monsieur
trudeau à vous la parole d'abord merci
monsieur poulin je me souviens d'avoir
visité là bas aussi à plusieurs années
et il le rayonnement de
l'entrepreneuriat et l'activité
économique est bien connue chez vous la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre oui on est les
très présente pendant cette endémie mais
aussi avant cette pandémie c'est pour ça
qu'on a fait des investissements aux
comptines faire des investissements en
formation de la main d'oeuvre en
immigration mais vous serez peut-être
intéressé par l'instat if al embauche
qu'on propose qui vont vous aider à
augmenter les salaires que vous pouvez
offrir à vous à vous à vous employer
pour encourager les gens de venir
chercher un travail parce qu'on sait que
cette reprise économique elle doit se
passer rapidement et partout pays merci
monsieur trudeau monsieur autour merci
monsieur poulin j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour les entrepreneurs les fermes
familiales dans la beauce et les
pénuries de minder vingtaine risque dans
toutes les régions et on doit s'attaquer
ça c'est pourquoi c'est dans mon contrat
avec les québécoises et les québécois je
vais donner plus de pouvoirs en
immigration pour le québec 1 c'est très
important particulièrement pour les
travailleurs étrangers dans le secteur
agricole s'est totalement nécessaire
d'avoir des travailleurs aussi on doit
avoir une approche de collaboration sur
la formation et on doit réduire les
programmes d'urgence comme les pays où
les eaux parce que on n'a rien généré et
on doit cibler sur le travail après la
pandémie merci monsieur autour de madame
paule vous que vous clôturez cette
portion oui merci monsieur poulin pour
la question a encore un exemple d'une
autre question notre jeu qu'on devrait
être au parlement discuter parce que les
gens et les entreprises ont encore
besoin d'être parce que nous sommes
encore dans une pandémie alors j'ai
beaucoup d'options à l'immigration la
formation
coordination et collaboration
il faut collaborer coordonnée avec à les
entreprises à pour savoir où sont les
lacunes et comment les remplir et il
faut avoir une meilleure formation qui
correspond pas aux besoins des
entreprises aussi et je sais que les
travailleurs travailleuses veut va voir
ça et puis l'immigration aussi nous
sommes un pays qui peut accueillir
beaucoup de personnes à cette solution
si merci madame paule alors monsieur
poulet merci beaucoup d'avoir partagé
votre perspective avec nous vous
sentez-vous éclairé par les réponses des
chefs
oui ce fut bien instructif
merci messieurs poule à une bonne soirée
si monsieur poulin vraiment c'est très
apprécié c'est peut-être la question
dont on nous parle plus la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre quand on voyage un peu au
pays monsieur blanchet monsieur trudeau
dans une confrontation adieu monsieur
blanchet d'abord vous dites sur pour le
secteur culturel les eaux donc là la pcr
s'est terminée en fait ce qu'on désigne
par je verrai sur un échange cordial
qu'une confrontation mais nous ce qu'on
dit c'est après avoir fait le tour des
régions du québec et plusieurs fois
plutôt qu'une ce qu'on a observé des
gens des entreprises en particulier de
petites entreprises dans le secteur des
services parce que les très grandes
entreprises restent concurrentes pour
attirer la main d'oeuvre chez elle on a
observé un phénomène de pénurie
demandeurs des restaurants fermés des
stations d'essence fermées des
communautés qui se disent si quelqu'un
veut participer à la halle aux villages
il pourra pas me dugas revanchards ce
genre d'enjeu là on les a observés et
les gens demandaient expressément pour
arrêtez la paix si ça me semble un peu
dur il pourrait y avoir une quatrième
vague plus forte que ce qu'on observe
maintenant qui sait peut-être une
cinquième on connaît pas l'avenir ce
programme là pour redevenir nécessaires
et utiles pour l'instant sauf dans le
domaine des arts et du tourisme sous ses
traits singuliers je pense qu'il doit
être suspendu pour le bien de l'économie
je suis
d'accord que dans toutes mes tournées au
québec c'est ça revient et depuis des
années c'est pas la pandémie qui a créé
cette pénurie de main d'oeuvre c'est pas
la pcu ni à la paix soeur qui l'a créé
et nous avons baissé le niveau de l'apc
1re jusqu'à 300 dollars par semaine ce
qui est en dessous du salaire minimum
mais nous reconnaissons que oui pour une
relance économique plus forte nous
devons faire les investissements à
appuyer des entreprises appuyées
l'embauchent de main d'oeuvre c'est pour
ça qu'on met de l'avant un incitatif al
embauche qu'on continue à vouloir
augmenter l'immigration qu'on continue à
faire plus pour la formation de la main
d'oeuvre et de l'appui direct pour les
entreprises on va continuer d'être là
pour les gens ça veut dire les
travailleurs mais ça veut aussi dire les
entreprises c'est ce qu'on a fait
pendant la pandémie c'est ce qu'on va
continuer de permettre un j invite le
gouvernement quel qu'il soit et dans ce
contexte une renata puis a travaillé sur
la productivité comment fait on pour
créer plus de richesse avec moins de
monde vous travaillez sur la
productivité pour annoncer des promesses
d'emploi améliorer la productivité des
entreprises
sur ce qu'on est en train de faire avec
un programme digital pour les petites
entreprises pour faire un virage
numérique loin ils ont su faire mettre
plus de productivité j'aurai l'occasion
d'y revenir merci effectivement c'était
tout à fait cordiale monsieur blanchet
surtout madame paule monsieur singh
manhas droit de parole je reviens sur la
pcr monsieur o'toole clairement la fin
octobre le premier ministre arrive quoi
on doit réduire les programmes d'urgence
dans une manière et quitte à arrêter
réduire arrêter si il n'ya par une
graisse qu'avec une cinquième vague de
la pandémie on doit cibler sur la santé
le bien-être des canadiens des québécois
mais on doit avoir une relance
économique
je suis clairement laissé tout à fait
crise l'hôtellerie les restaurants le
secteur touristique on a un plan
spécifique pour les pme ancré je ne suis
pas d'accord pas de tube sur ce que je
sais qu'on a vu si quelqu'un ne
travaille pas parce qu'il gagne 1200
pièces ce n'est pas un problème de la
paix si heureux c'est un problème des
bons salaires les gens veut travailler
mais je veux tourner à au sujet que coût
de la vie la coût de la vie augmente la
prix pour les maisons à mantes monsieur
trudeau aviez six ans pour faire quelque
chose mais pendant le temps qu'elle
était premier ministre et jusqu'à
maintenant coup d'acheter une maison à
augmenter dit monsieur vous essayer aux
intérêts donc si tous difficile pour les
gens c'est que je vous en parlais de
champ mais là le sujet c'est la pcr vous
vous dites on continue oui bien sûr et
bien on doit continuer d aider des gens
s'est claqué on est dans un quartier bac
et
j'aimerais qu'on est invité à les chefs
qui apprend ce que c'est le moment de
terminer les prestations de venir à dans
ma circonscription pourvoira légion
marchandises et à qui travaillent dans
les services essentiels a qui ont encore
besoin à de cette prestation pour
survivre et sait même pas s à ces îles
sont menacées par des expulsions de leur
logement
il y en avait on a besoin de ça et je
vais aller en plus et dire que c'est le
moment de commencer à considérer le
remplacement de ses prestations
d'urgence avec une raie venus du sud 6
ans
minimum permanent parce qu'on voit qu'il
y a des lacunes et on ne réussit pas à
je suis d'accord et encore que de ce
qu'on a vu ce qu'on a vu dans cette
pandémie c'est vraiment la décision
monsieur trudeau au lieu de s'assurer
que les grandes entreprises qui ont pris
l'argent public qui l'a exploité que la
mâchoire avec the thing d'utiliser dans
un mauvais manière sûre unis de faire ça
avec ses conclusions à couper allait aux
gens du dos exerce au nazisme qui va
arriver avec l'inde et des émissions to
do on va voir les dépenses sans limite
et il y adhérer et à la main côté vous
devez vous découpez les gens doublé
location ce sont des travailleurs je
vais lutter pour les autres études
cette entreprise
j'appelle
j'appelle maintenant ma collègue hélène
buzzetti à venir vous poser des
questions et j'en profite pour vous
rappeler pendant qu'hélène s'installe
que pendant les débats si vous parlez en
même temps ça ne fonctionne pas ça sera
le dernier avertissement mais en soirée
poser des questions sur la mission oui
c'est bien la passion mais on a la foi
c'est rue d'auron commence avec vous
l'inflation cette année a atteint 3
points 7 % c'est un record en dix ans
les sens l'épicerie à peu près tout
coûte plus cher et beaucoup disent que
ce sont vos dépenses colossales qui sont
en partie responsables
alors quelles garanties autant que les
milliards de plus que vous proposez
encore de dépenser ne vont pas encore
faire augmenter le coût de la vie c'est
une très bonne question mais les
investissements qu'on est en train de
faire comme les garderies à 10 dollars à
travers le pays plus de place au québec
comme des investissements pour aider les
familles à épargner pour un premier à
l'achat d'une première maison les
investissements qu'on est en train de
faire pour soutenir les milieux
culturels les milieux touristiques les
travailleurs à travers l'industrie on
est là pour soutenir les gens j'ai fait
une promesse au début de la pandémie
d'être là pour les gens aussi longtemps
que ça prendrait et s'adonner non
seulement des résultats pour les sociale
mais pour la croissance économique et
une chose ou est ce que ça va pas créer
une surchauffe s'il ya encore plus
d'inflation les taux d'intérêt ont
demandé qu'est ce qui arrive aux gens
qui ont beaucoup de grosse d'hypothèque
pas aux voeux créé cette croissance
économique mais oui nous allons gérer
cette inflation parce que nous devons
garder l'abordabilité pour la famille
merci c'est tout ça qu'on a monsieur o
toole vous avez déposé votre cadre
financier il ya à peine deux heures de
ça alors vous nous excuserez si on n'a
pas eu le temps vraiment de le
décortiquer si j'ai bien compris vous
gardez à peu près toutes les dépenses du
dernier budget libéral vous ajoutez des
dépenses conservatrice que vous allez
quand même équilibré pied des est facile
des fils et expliquez moi ça j'suis pas
sûr de comprendre avec notre plan pour
le rétablissement du canada ont véhiculé
près le budget au cours d'une décennie
avec un approche sur les les
travailleurs et une relance économique
dans tous les secteurs et dans toutes
les régions c'est pourquoi on va voir
des investissements au aider les
familles avec la santé mentale avec les
pme en crise mais on doit avoir une
relance économique pour une économie
fort et on a un plan pour ça il y à une
crise du coût de la vie maintenant à
cause de dépenses sans limite par
monsieur mais justement vous mais vous
promettez de les garder ses dépenses
lors comment vous réconcilier ça c'est
quoi c'est l'effet magique autour je me
trouve absolument on a reproduit coulé
près le budget mais on doit créer des
emplois notre premier palier et de créer
un million d'emplois en un an c'est tout
ça qu'on a monsieur blanchet tout
indique qu'on se dirige peut-être dans
l'élection d'un gouverneur très
minoritaire ce qui voudrait dire qu'on
aurait besoin de l'appui de deux partis
d'opposition pour faire adopter des lois
ou à la chambre des communes dans ce
contexte quelle serait votre condition
pour appuyer un budget est ce que par
exemple 28 milliards dont on parlait
tout à l'heure en santé pour les
provinces et non négociable pour vous
c'est passablement non négociable en
effet bon moi je me pose la question je
me pose la question à ce stade dans la
campagne y'at-il un des partis majeurs
qui mérite une majorité est ce que
quelqu'un que démontrer donnez moi les
deux mains sur le volant de jean charest
à l'époque là pendant quatre ans avec
quelque chose qui ressemble à un plein
qu'on évoque comme une incantation mais
un espèce de vision qui nous amènent
quelque part le bloc garde sa
philosophie titubant ont recours si
mauvais on vote contre lyon sinéquanone
le transfert a senti sont une condition
sinequanone mais c'est les trois
principaux partis ne se sont pas engagés
à verser 28 milliards de francs c'est
parce que j'entends beaucoup de mépris
sur les compétences du québec comme si
quand ces canadiens c'est meilleur que
quand ces québécois toutes les provinces
pas juste le québec c'est pas un truc
d'indépendantistes toutes les provinces
disent transfert sans condition tous
séparés 6% par année ces 28 milliards +6
% par résultats qu'on a merci monsieur
singh vous proposez de dépenser des
milliards de plus que les libéraux vous
dites que vous allez faire payer les
ultra-riches même vous parlez d'amazon
avec respect monsieur singh chef base os
et aux états unis et on surestime
toujours le revenu de la lutte à
l'évasion fiscale qu'est ce que vous
dites aux gens qui trouvent que
peut-être ça repose sur la pensée
magique bat là je pense que c'est
vraiment question d égalité si vous
travaillez ici au canada vous avez une
entreprise ici au canada vous payez
votre juste part mais les entreprises
comme les géants du web n'est payée par
le juste pas assez et injuste donc on
l'a vu les autres pays qui ont commencé
france à dick et on va taxer le revenu
donc on a dit clairement on est prêts
d'investir dans les gens mais pas comme
monsieur trudeau ont mis sur youtube qui
vont couper l'aide aux gens ou mettre
plus de pression sur les épaules des
gens on est la seule partie avec un plan
crédible qui dit on veut s'assurer que
les milliers d'appels juste parce que
cet argent là seront au rendez vous je
pense à votre taxe sur le patrimoine les
riches peuvent déplacer leurs avoirs et
si les revenus sont pollock plus de
déficit non je pense que premièrement
une taxe sur les revenus ou notre pays a
commencé ça on peut arrêter les paires
crédits fiscaux et les échappatoires sur
les bons mesures pour gagner plus de
revenus pour investir dans les gens
merci madame paule vous avez en partage
avec monsieur signe de ne pas encore
nous avoir donné votre cadre financier
mais enfin vous proposer un revenu
minimum garanti
quand on regarde l'ampleur du déficit
est ce que on peut vraiment se permettre
une pcu permanente on sait que le bureau
budgétaire le bureau du parlement
budgétaire a déjà dit que oui en fait
c'est possible et oui en fait avec une
revenu minimum garanti on l'appelle une
ré venu à de subsistance a garanti que
sont les vrais à presque 50 % des
personnes hors de pauvreté et on sait
aussi qu'on peut payer pour ça et on
sait aussi que malgré tous nos efforts
collective qu'il y a des lacunes qui
restent et chaque fois que quelqu'un
dans un pays autant que riche que le
nôtre 30 dans un de ces lacunes c'est
une honte on parle on parle pénurie de
main d'oeuvre les huit cent mille postes
vacants comme on les compte si on les
paye les gens à rester à la maison
il faut payer les légions une salaire à
dont il peut gagner il peut payer le
logement am c'est le moment pour à une
grève dont une ravine de subsistance et
je sais qu'il ya des autres familles
d'utiliser d'accord avec moi merci
madame paule débats ouverts vous avez
tous le droit de parole le hasard a
voulu que je commence par monsieur singh
mais je veux vous parler est le plus
clairement possible de garderie on
parlait de pénurie de main d'oeuvre au
québec on l'a vu ça a été une
accélération fantastique pour l'accès
des hauts femmes sur le marché du
travail les libéraux proposent un plat
je veux que vous vous positionnez puis
monsieur o toole évidemment que je vous
posais la question que vous pensez qu'on
va vous poser qu'est ce qui arrive avec
le 6 milliards et monsieur singh les
garderies que c'est une bonne idée
est-ce conforme ce là dessus oui c'est
une excellent idée je veux saluer tous
les militants qui ont poussé le
gouvernement de livrer les marchandises
mais je veux noté monsieur trudeau et
son parti ont promis ça depuis trois
décennies
ça veut dire 30 ans ils ont promis de la
faire et finalement ils ont commencé
mais la grande question c'est si
monsieur trudeau a vraiment voulu faire
quelque chose pourquoi il a déclenché
une action au lieu de continuer le
travail c'est complètement inacceptable
et les gens ne peux pas croire en
monsieur trudeau surtout risque parce
que votre cadre financier été dévoilée à
quelques heures et là c'est clair vous
abolissez le 6 milliards pour le québec
et les autres provinces donc il n'y aura
pas parce que vous jouiez sur les deux
tableaux il n'y aura pas de chèque
envoyé au québec pour le programme de
garderies si votre programme de crédit
d'ing on va aider les familles québécois
immédiatement et on va aider les
familles à faible revenu avec une monte
à 2 75% et je vais toujours respecté les
jambes des compétences incluant le
système au québec et c'est pourquoi on
va pouvoir donner avec le gouvernement
de monsieur legault en toi tu que la
vacation et on a une budget dans notre
plafond aux anges il ya je vais avoir
une transition parce que notre pain va
aider tous les familles québécoises
brise et leurs familles vont
en charge mais c'est une surprise que
monsieur libre
mais pas très bien monsieur où tout ne
comprend même pas le système de garderie
au québec on a voulu utiliser pour
s'inspirer à travers le pays il dit
qu'il va renvoyer un crédit d'impôt aux
familles les plus vulnérables au québec
les plus familles les plus vulnérables
au québec ne paie pas pour leurs
garderies ses couverts par l'état alors
il n'en voit rien et l'évidence il a
saisi dans votre gérer ces 6 milliards
de dollars qui vont créer 37 milieu de
la zone en garderie c'est des familles
québécoises qui attendent depuis des
mois et des années des fois pour des
places en garderie qui veut dire non on
crée surtout lassé
de
ce trouble à travers le pays et monsieur
et autres tous craquer ça je m'en remets
à rotana de préfet de discipline sur
voie pour les chats d'abord le plan des
conservateurs parce qu'on passe deux
jours de plein plein plein plein plein
plein plein c'est 6 milliards de moins
dans les poches de l'état québécois j'ai
très hâte d'entendre monnaie dans
l'expression de la grande affection des
conservateurs pour le québec ce que
monsieur legault va en penser
lorsqu'ils vont réagir et cette annonce
là l'autre élément je vous rappelle que
ce système que monsieur trudeau merci
trouve exceptionnel a été créée par
madame marois et c'est pour moi la
preuve la démonstration que regarder au
québec des programmes administrés par le
québec créé par le québec on est capable
de faire ça on n'a pas besoin dans aucun
secteur d'une ingérence et de conditions
générales pour faire nos affaires je
suis d'accord avec city où les homicides
ont laissé une femme par les surnoms jeu
qui impacte les femmes plus que les
autres et je me demande aussi assis les
autres chefs de parti ici a aussi une
âme s'il avait plus de femmes qui
représentait leur parti surtout comme
chef si on aurait tardé à des décennies
pour avoir quelque chose qui est un
droit et qui est nécessaire pour les
femmes à travailler alors oui absolument
pour la garderie à universel absolument
et oui c'est topi a pour moi les autres
femmes qui travaillent avec les enfants
qu'on n'a pas fait pendant la dernière
sensation du parlement samedi la turquie
offre des finances répond à vos points
de vue pour léguer un problème et
monsieur o'toole vous êtes moi j'ai un
autre idée alors je n'enverrais pas le
chèque de 6000 on va collaborer et
coordonné avec le gouvernement on a un
budget elles on note que plafond chiffré
pour ça parce que on doit votre le baiia
l'encaissé et tout ça
merci et programmes à ce que monsieur le
chef vincent ça va très bien europe et
le thym le temps pour chacun six
exemplaires prochain thème
[Musique]
environnement thèmes incontournables
évidemment une question
fort intéressant tout à fait rarement
l'urgence climatique nous a paru aussi
tangible qu'au cours des derniers mois
le canada a su fokine de chaleur cet été
en juin la canicule fait des centaines
de morts dans l'ouest du pays il le fait
car en 9,5 degrés à l'étude en colombie
britannique
un record et d'ailleurs le canada se
réchauffe deux fois plus vite que la
moyenne mondiale la solution pour éviter
la catastrophe climatique on la connaît
c'est un fait il faut réduire de manière
draconienne les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre c'est un enjeu qui préoccupe
énormément les jeunes générations qui
vont avoir à subir les conséquences des
décisions actuelles charles leduc à 11
ans ont le joint à cinq lettres en
montérégie bonsoir charles
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
bienvenue au débat des chefs alors toi
quand on regarde les feux de forêt les
canicules les ouragans qui se
multiplient sur la planète sat inquiète
il ya une question que j'aimerais poser
au chef on t'écoute
oui c'est vrai ça mais kate alors que
comptez vous faire pour diminuer
l'utilisation des énergies fossiles au
canada je faisais aussi charles que tu
t'inquiètes pas juste pour ton avenir à
toi
oui et aussi pour celui de mes enfants
merci beaucoup char alors en un garçon
de 11 ans s'inquiète déjà pour l'avenir
de ses enfants
monsieur trudeau qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez sur les énergies fossiles
d'abord merci charles dette ici merci
pour ta question une question que
j'entends régulièrement pas juste de mes
enfants mes d'enfants comme toi à
travers le pays c'est pour ça que nous
avons mis sur pied un plan extrêmement
ambitieux pour le dire très simplement
on met un plafond sur le sec les
émissions du secteur gazier et pétrolier
pour le diminuer jusqu'à 9 0 1 on sait
qu'il faut réduire nos émissions de gaz
à effet de serre du secteur pétrolier
gazier on va aussi aider à ce que tout
le monde peut s'acheter les voitures
électriques d'ici 2035 toutes les
nouvelles voitures au canada vont être
électrique ces deux ports concret qu'on
va livrer pour toi et ta génération
charles merci monsieur autour à vous la
parole
merci pour la question mes enfants sont
jeunes comme chargé l'environnement le
changement climatique est important pour
moi comme une paire de famille c'est
pour cours en avril on a lancé notre
politique sur le changement climatique
on doit atteindre nos objectifs de paris
et on a un plan de réduire nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre tout en créant
les emplois et les opportunités après le
pont demi on a un plan avec beaucoup de
détails chance avec un prix sur le
carbone avec une coupe de parle
personnel sur le carbone on va utiliser
la technologie comme la circuit stration
l'hydrogène et on va avoir une approche
de collaboration avec le québec sur les
véhicules électriques à oman agir charrs
merci madame paule merci beaucoup charge
pour la question mais bon en fait nous
avons à éviter beaucoup de genna
militons à pour des tables rondes autour
des derniers mois c'est une source
d'angoissé pour moi honnêtement charles
on cherche d'être un peu un parti
rassembleur mais sur le climat nous
sommes à part nous sommes partis à part
parce qu'on sait très bien que c'est
impossible d'investir dans les oléoducs
donné à un projet de forage la
d'exploration abdallah fracturation
hydraulique est d'atteindre nos cibles
il y a une seule choix sur le climat a
dans cette élection mais on veut
travailler avec les autres partis merci
madame paule monsieur blanchet chef
futur papa d'abord le groupe d'étude
international sur le climat au établi
que le canada est un très très mauvais
élèves en matière de changements
climatiques
c'est pas en mettant dix milliards de
dollars par année dans l'est du tri
pétrolières ou pays des milliards de
plus que ce soit dans la chaude un tuyau
qui sert à transporter du pétrole en
prétendant que ça va permettre de
réduire les gaz à effet de serre qu'on
va y arriver nous on pense qu'il faut
mettre un plafond au niveau de
production actuelle de pétrole a
commencé à descendre des centres d'essai
on est même prêt à aider à financer la
démarche pour l'alberta et on a aussi
parlé d'une idée aujourd'hui de faire en
sorte que le financement des banques
base du pétrole vers les énergies vertes
merci monsieur blanchet monsieur signe
merci et félicitations charles c'est
incroyable vous avez posé une question
tous ces personnes ont vu sa fille
station à et je veux dire que c'est
vraiment grand inquiétés pour moi aussi
je vais devenir comme vous voulez faire
je vis devenu un papa bientôt léger des
peur pour mon enfant et si vraiment une
en jeu qu'on doit faire face et leurs
qualités ces messieurs trop d'eau ici
elle a dit qu'elle veut réduire les
émissions et les manques et chaque cible
elle a augmenté les subventions aux
pétrolières et il a continué d exempter
les grands pros loire on veut faire face
à cette crise climatique on va éliminer
les subventions aux pétrolières on va à
vous donner une avenir brillant ses
mains mon engagement merci monsieur
c'est merci beaucoup charte a posé une
question que beaucoup beaucoup de
canadiens se pose continue à t'engager
puis à t'impliquer passé une très belle
soirée
merci
très apprécié merci beaucoup charles
salut
je poursuis sur le même sujet monsieur
o'toole et monsieur blanchet vous avez
la parole
dans le fond la question que les gens se
pose est simple surtout vous êtes le
premier à répondre comment réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre tout
en augmentant la production de pétrole
si possible de réduire les émissions de
gaz et verts tout en créant les emplois
on va avoir des programmes sur la
carboneutralité dans le secteur
énergétique danoise on doit utiliser la
technologie comme l'hydrogène ici au
québec on va voir les approches en
partenariat avec les grands émetteurs de
réduire nos émissions et c'est pourquoi
on a lancé notre plateforme en avril
c'est un enjeu important et je doit
rétablir la confiance dans cet enjeu
mais on a un plan d'attribution
tout en créant les emplois pour une
relance économique
la voiture du conte de fées va se
transformer en citrouille bientôt il est
impossible il est impossible de réduire
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
augmentant l'extraction la production et
l'exportation de pétrole il est par
contre possible de créer plus de
richesses en s'investissant dans les
énergies vertes dans l'innovation dans
la transformation dans les régions du
québec de nos propres ressources
naturelles avec nos propres centres de
recherche et aux manières de faire
plusieurs manières de faire mieux une
manière d' exporter ce savoir faire
c'est me sens plus humaniste
hydrocarbures et les énergies fossiles
s'est terminée sur branchez vous avez
dit ça la semaine passée c'est possible
d'utiliser la technologie là c'est cuit
stration de carbone et
musique 67 de l'aluminium dans le
circuit hongrois avoine relance
économique dans les régions aussi et
vous avez pris des décisions comme un
ancien ministre dans l'environnement au
québec vous avez approuvé les grues
grande émetteurs au québec samba on doit
travailler en étroite collaboration avec
les provinces monsieur blanche monsieur
blanchet jeu vous allez droit de
réplique mais je vais vous citer je vous
souhaite de vous
je vais vous dire sans aucune hésitation
le gouvernement du québec à l'intention
d'avancer dans l'exploitation de la
filière pétrolière au québec 14 février
2013 en commission parlementaire il
françois blanchette donc vous y avez cru
à l'exploitation pétrolière pour le
québec je faisais je faisais partie d'un
gros mais au fait vous déposez votre
temps et plus ça se serait offert
j'avais dit comme ministre de
l'environnement ce que mon gouvernement
disait puis je pense que tout le monde
était sincère ma job à moi c'était le
contrôle et allait y avoir un bape après
l'étape d'exploration si jamais les
autres amis s'ils sortent les autres
quand ils veulent parler j'imagine
qu'ils ont été à même école ça me fait
abuser de répondre à chacun y trouvera
ce que j'ai fait depuis huit ans à
répétition de toute façon je répète d'or
j'ai pas dit que la séquestration était
une solution j'ai dit ça n'existe pas
sauf dans les arbres et monsieur trudeau
rendu à 0
de répliques a été donné sa parole
madame paul the thing monsieur trudeau
je reviens ce grand dilemme canadien
pays producteurs de pétrole qui veut
être un pays vert en même temps on
s'aperçoit que depuis 25 ans et
irréconciliables non ça ne l'est pas
c'est les pas justement parce qu'on sait
que même si on peut pas à passer dans
cette transition du jour au lendemain ça
se fait dans les années à venir parce qu
on est en train de voir ce que ça donne
les investissements que nous sommes en
train de faire à dans les technologies
vertes dans lé renouvelables dans la
transformation de notre de notre secteur
énergique c'est pour ça qu'on veut
mettre un plafond sur les émissions du
secteur pétrolier a dit le belge et
jusqu'à 9 0 et on va à investir dans les
voitures électriques pour pour aider
tout le monde à en acheter
malheureusement on est un choix je dois
avant tout et surtout honnêtement vous
aviez 600 de faire quelque chose et ça
me rend triste j'ai aucune joie de dire
ça mais en six ans vous avez le pire
bilan du sheed g7 et l'arrière et tisser
vous avez promis d éliminer les
subventions aux pétrolières une bonne
promis mais au lieu de la faire vous
avez augmente les augmenter les
subventions aux pétrolières
comment les gens peuvent vous croquer
nous sommes nous sommes le seul parti de
dire clairement que nous allons arrêter
de construire des oléoducs
nous allons nous allons à arrêter de
soutenir des programmes d âme à la
fracturation hydraulique
nous n'allons pas subventionné à le
secteur pétrolier et je dis ça comme la
soeur de quelqu'un qui travaillait comme
ouvrier en alberta dans le secteur
pétrolier je le dis pour moment mon
frère à l'avenir ici au canada oui c'est
l'énergie mais c'est l'énergie
renouvelable je suis deux ans alors je
suis rentré de traîner derrière tous nos
partenaires internationale il ya une
grille ouvrage qui se passe maintenant
l'avenir misaya polaire qui l'a fait
d'accord je suis tout à fait d'accord ce
qu'on doit faire c'est de prendre des
décisions cirier parce qu'on a une
grande hi-fi adjoint droit investir dans
l'énergie renouvelable comme droits
électifs ikki l'actif y est les
transports mais on ne peut pas se
permettre une quatre ans de plus et
monsieur trudeau un grand parleur mais
petit faiseur
la question en bien du droit de régler
un pied droit de réplique on voit ce
soir tous les différents partis disent
oui on est sérieux sur l'environnement
parce qu'on est un pays de science et de
respect pour la science la réalité c'est
qu'il faut se fier aux experts et les
examens les environnementalistes les
climatologues à les économistes disent
tous que c'est le parti libéral qui est
le vôtre
celui-ci va s'est terminée à merci
c'est terminé combien
que tu sois pas là ce pôle environnement
très bien si ce n est pas de tuner si
j'avais planète n'ont pas le journée
j'habite maintenant pas de journées à
venir poser ses questions au chef
d'un soir patrice bonsoir monsieur singh
vous voulez aider les villes à rendre le
transport collectif gratuit mais elle
manque d'argent pour financer les
services actuels qui en plus sont
insuffisants comment ça peut fonctionner
donc merci pour la question on veut
investir en collaboration avec les
municipalités pour les aider pour le
transport en commun parce qu'on sait un
des grands producteurs des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre c'est la transpose
transportation donc si on peut investir
dans le transport collectif si on peut
les électrifier si on peut aider les
municipalités en travaillant ensemble
avec les provinces et territoires ça
veut vraiment aider dans la lutte contre
la crise climatique mais quelqu'un doit
refermer le dollar est ce que l'autobus
devrait gratuit pour lui je pense que
c'est une option mais on va donner
l'option municipalité mais ce qu'on veut
faire c'est vraiment de faire des
investissements énormes dans le
transport collectif parce que c'est
important de le faire monsieur trudeau
voulait plafonner les émissions de gaz
et de pétrole n'est vous octroyez encore
des permis de forage entre autres à
terre-neuve quand mettrait fin aux
nouveaux projets tout d'abord avec un
plafond sur les émissions du secteur
pétrolier et gazier ça va être
extrêmement difficile de à créer des
nouveaux investissements parce qu'il
faudrait réduire les émissions actuelles
parce que si ça dont on a besoin oui au
fil des années on a regardé certains
projets et on a appliqué une des
critères extrêmement rigoureuses pour
les approuver mais nous allons continuer
notre sérieux avec un prix sur la
pollution c'est pourtant nécessaire et
remettez oui le plafond il est à partir
de quelle année ça diminue à quel rythme
est ce que ça va être une pente douce ou
une porte abreu va être la pente ça va
être la pente nécessaires décidées par
les experts qu'on est en train de
regarder mais ça fait quatre cinq ans
que déjà les émissions sont plafonnés
eelv ont pu augmenter marc en pole en
2021 tous les partis fédéraux autre plan
environnement et selon l'ancien chef du
parti vert en colombie-britannique votre
plan n'est même pas le meilleur est ce
que votre parti a perdu un peu sa raison
d'être
il a tort et je le dis tout simplement
moi je suis avocat je suis analyste je
suis énormément pragmatique mais quand
je cherchais une partie à joignez à je
me demandais quel parti avec le meilleur
appelant pour notre avenir c'est le
parti vert on sait très bien c'est
impossible de continuer à extraire aller
les produits à pétrolier de continuer à
construire les au lieu de continuer à
donner le faire des dérapages de la
figuration c'était impossible de le
faire alors notre programme c'est
pratique c'est faisable mais c'est aussi
audacieux à il faut le faire monsieur
autour vous voulez geler la taxe carbone
des libéraux et créez un compte
d'épargné ou plus on consomme d'essence
plus on reçoit de crédit d'achat comment
est ce qu'on fait pour polluer moins en
consommant plus on a lancé notre plan en
avril et votre compte d'épargné
personnelle pour le carbone c'est votre
argent et si vous transférez votre
argent entre votre camp c'est votre
argent mais vous allez prendre les
décisions de réduire votre empreinte
carbone c'est une approche innovante et
on doit atteindre nos objectifs et c'est
pourquoi on a lancé notre politique en
avril paris / ami avec deux vitesses est
la grande gagnante avec votre place est
eux qui ralentissent leur part les
hackers il doit prendre les décisions
pour les échappées vers avec le compte
épargne personnelle et comme j'ai dit on
va travailler en étroite collaboration
avec les provinces avec les grands
donateurs et on a un plan avec beaucoup
de détails parce que c'est un enjeu
important pour notre pays et pour notre
monde monsieur blanchet monsieur vous
voulez que le lien québec qui le
troisième québec lévis soient financées
par une enveloppe verte du fédéral
si c'est dans une autre province c'est
ce que vous diriez la même chose ou est
ce que les nouvelles rod sont seulement
écologique au québec comme parti qui
défend les juridictions des provinces
était dans une autre province est raide
et montez de bonnes chances que je m'en
mêle pas parce que c'est que ce que je
préconise pour le québec ou si je
réitère encore une fois et je suis prêt
à le faire encore de nombreuses fois
c'est une juridiction des provinces ce
sont des infrastructures qui lie les
municipalités et les taux québécois il
revient à l'état québécois de faire les
consultations les évaluations
environnementales
je suis convaincu qu'ils aient la
conservation environnementale et que ça
peut être fait et je gagne à faire c'est
une enveloppe verte du fédéral est ce
qu'une enveloppe vert du fédéral devrait
financer l'étalement urbain dans une
enveloppe et l'infrastructure du fédéral
et le gouvernement du québec a demandé
que l' enveloppe globale
d'infrastructures du fédéral parce que
c'est la juridiction de québec soit
donné à québec québec heureux sa
discussion avec levi avec québec et la
population qui aura des exigences à
caractère environnemental
parce que le gouvernement québécois
devra aller chercher
l'acceptabilité sociale merci merci paul
la merci de ceux blanche un débat ouvert
alors vous pourrez reprendre sur
l'environnement je vous donne juste cinq
chiffres
surtout vous voulez réduire vous les
cibles de 30% possible c'est 30 pour ça
ce trudeau 40 madame paule rousset 60
monsieur singh monsieur blanchet 50 pour
ça mais la réalité et les gens lui ça ou
le répète artistique depuis 24 ans
aucune cible fixée par le canada n'a été
atteint alors monsieur trudeau premier à
lancer ce débat ouvert comment les gens
peuvent suivre et faire tout d'abord
selon tous les experts et les
scientifiques
on est déjà en voie d'atteindre de
dépasser les cibles qu'on avait fixé à
paris à cinq ans on va réduire de 36 %
du 1 d'ici 2030 ceci fait qu'on propose
d'aller encore plus loin pour aller à
40% et les gens savent qu'ils ont besoin
d'un gouvernement qui va agir
concrètement et de façon ambitieuse sur
les changements climatiques
malheureusement les conservateurs 20
revenir au plan harper et briser leur
promesse de paris paris paris est une
joie on continue d'augmenter nos
objectifs nos cibles et lui revient des
aventures je vois les canadiens méritent
un gouvernement qui va livrer sur nos
objectifs monsieur to do chaque année
comme ministre il a manqué six objectifs
et les canadiens mary un plan concret et
c'est pourquoi on a lancé notre plan en
avril avec un prix sur le carbone et on
doive réduire nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et on doit atteindre nos
objectifs de
livrer sur les enjeux importants pour
les jeux 5 je suis je suis en train de
dire quelque chose bizarre je suis tout
à fait d'accord que monsieur trudeau
avec monsieur au touquet monsieur
trudeau a manqué chaque cible mais
surtout doit faire la même chose et je
vais partager une histoire de commencer
une nigériane j'ai rencontré une jeune
femme à monter elle a dit que c'est pour
les pros c'est quoi le point des
possibles mes études de trouver un
partenaire de commencer famille quand
j'ai peur pour l'avenir je ne sais pas
ce qui va arriver dans l'avenir c'est ça
la question donc on ne peut pas se
permettre d'avoir quelqu'un qui dit des
belles paroles mais innovera des actions
concrètes on a compris monsieur blanchet
j'appellerai les cibles actuelles de
petites lâchetés avant on fixait les
cibles selon le seuil de kyoto 1990
apprécions de 2005 parce qu'on se met un
autre cap plus aucun point départ sa
part ben nous on dit 37 points 5 % sur
le cas précédent ça va faire 51% sur
2005 et ça c'est à peu près ce que les
américains s'engagent à faire donc le
canada et même pas prêt à aller aussi
loin que les américains qui sont aussi
de très grands producteurs et
consommateurs de pétrole je pense qu'un
petit peu de courage et dre il existe
des mécanismes de contrôle dont la
bourse du carbone que j'ai eu la chance
de si je vais prendre ce fait ce point
je vais parler à sincèrement directement
à au canadien kent diane parce que vous
savez votre intuition j'en suis sûr
c'est que ça ne fonctionne pas ça ne
fonctionne pas du tout et le canada est
en train de bon d'abord de rater une
opportunité à historique d'être sur le
premier rang à d'une économie verte est
aussi que nous sommes sur un chemin à
une destination de nulle part c'est à
vous de décider pendant ces élections
est ce que vous voulez continuer sur le
même chemin de 6 ans de faillite ou est
ce que vous voulez aller dans une autre
direction
c'est ça vraiment le choix et désolé
mais c'est dans l'esprit on veut dire
que tous les scientifiques sont d'accord
même les scientifiques dont à notre
fonction publique a dit qu'avec autre
plan on ne reste pas même à une moitié
de votre cible la réalité c'est que tous
les plans du trou sur le chef ici ce
soir compte sur la pensée magique sauf
le plan libéral il faut écouter les
experts faut écouter les scientifiques
les climatologues qui disent que sur le
parti libéral qui a le vrai le faire du
plan ambitieux comme les autres sinon
pas le plan à la hauteur pour lutter
contre et bien sûr alors c'est magique
c'est qui qui gardent leur emploi après
alors je suis un brin de chance et
céréales je souhaite bonne chance aux
gens une maison il ya une profession de
foi je vous avais demandé le pipeline
d'ipsen combien d'années puisque même
vous monsieur singh vous dites oui je
serai obligé de l'exploiter combien
d'années vite combien d'années vous
l'exploiter le pipeline j'ai dit que je
suis contre ces projets il est déjà
comblé leur continue d'être contre je
suis contre 7 projets dont vous le faire
mais je suis contre ce projet j'ai déjà
dit ça y arrive quoi donc quand on est
au gouvernement on va avoir c'est
exactement quoi la saturation ce truc
doublé contre
des communautés autochtones qui veulent
acheter cet oléoduc
ils vont continuer de l'opérer jusqu à
ce qu on en est plus de besoins parce
qu'on va faire cette transition pour
diminuer les émissions du secteur et aux
gens essayent de voir si tu disque vingt
et un ans plus tôt à votre esprit
pétrole combien de temps au canada les
familles de l'ouest relance économique
aussi c'est possible de créer des
emplois tout en réduisant nos émissions
merci merci
je l'offre aux gens de l'alberta pour
entreprendre leur transition énergétique
parce qu'ils en ont gravement besoins
leurs économies dépendent trop du
pétrole merci les prochains thèmes
prochaines
semaines être une projet qui ne va pas à
donner même en dessous de revenus et en
plus à cette kia qui a
violé la souveraineté adea territoire à
oued souhaitait alors il a d'abord merci
à jean paul prochain
[Musique]
autochtone identité et culture j'en
profite pour dire aux gens qui nous
écoutent nous sommes je le dis je le
disais dans la grande galerie du musée
canadien de l'histoire dans une salle
dédiée à la culture autochtone
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que vous avez
peut-être aperçu des parties de totem
parce que dans le décor en cash certains
noms nous et demi quand vous parlez on
voit alors c'est pour ça vous avez une
question du site web oui on a tous été
profondément ébranlée par la découverte
de sépulture d'enfants autochtones qui
ont été trouvés par centaines sur les
sites ancien pensionnat c'est évident il
ya fort à faire pour parvenir à une
forme de réconciliation alors notre
prochain invité citoyen est très réussie
mots il est mort à qu'il est originaire
de la communauté de cannes et s'attaquer
on va aller le rejoindre à montréal
bonsoir monsieur simon
ségo bonsoir madame murs eux merci
beaucoup de votre présence alors les
derniers mois on certainement été
éprouvant pour vous on peut penser au
pensionnat mais on pense aussi à la mort
de joyce et chaque one à l'hôpital de
joliette comment est-ce qu'on peut
commencer à réparer ces injustices mais
puis je vois que vous avez avec vous
votre plume ce qui signifie dans la
tradition morale que c'est à votre tour
de prendre la rôle dans notre cercle de
discussion alors allez-y vous avez la
parole
en 2021 et les trains il est temps de
reconnaître que nous existons et que
nous partageons ce territoire la terre
de nos ancêtres avec les canadiens et
les québécois
pour entamer une réelle réconciliation
seriez vous prêt à inclure les langues
des premières nations des inuits et des
métis parmi les langues officielles du
canada gnahoua merci merci beaucoup
monsieur simon donc un sujet très
complexe et une question très clair très
simple messieurs blanchet à vous de
commencer monsieur simon bonsoir mes
hommages mes salutations très très
sincère je dirais de nation à nation
la partie qui relève de québec devra
être discuté avec québec et elle a été
soulevée dans les derniers jours est ce
que je constate c'est que québec dit que
le projet de loi 96 ne change pas ça
mais permettez moi de dire au niveau
fédéral ou dans la perspective parce que
vous avez utilisé les mots nous
partageons un même territoire et c'est
la réalité nous devons coexister de
façon enrichissante pour toutes les
nations la canadienne la québécoise les
premières nations sur ce même territoire
dans cet esprit là ma réponse est
clairement oui sur le territoire qui est
présentement le canada ou le québec les
langues autochtones doivent avoir une
reconnaissance officielle et est
assujettie à une juridiction qui sera
celle des peuples autochtones merci
monsieur blanchet monsieur trudeau merci
monsieur simon pour votre présence ici
ce soir et votre leadership
la réalité c'est que nous avons
travaillé pour co développer avec les
peuples autochtones datera vers ce pays
les protections et un statut officiel
pour les langues autochtones mais je
vous partage est un exemple très concret
pour moi défendre le bilinguisme
l'anglais le français au canada est
extrêmement important mais nous avons
pris a difficilement mais nous avons
pris la décision de nommer une
gouverneur ayral qui ne parlent pas nos
deux langues officielles parce qu'elle
parle une de nos langues officielles et
lino petite route qui n'en qu'elle a
apprise au nord du québec quand elle
était jeune pour moi ça démontre à quel
point nous devons valoriser cette
culture ces langues pour avancer tous
ensemble
merci
monsieur simon merci infiniment pour
votre présence aujourd'hui vous ajouter
quelque chose de spécial est important
et je suis tout à fait d'accord que on
doit reconnaître des langues autochtones
comme des langues officielles
c'est une petite chose qu'on peut faire
mais ça va avoir des impacts profonds
parce que ce qu'on doit faire pour la
justice autochtone c'est des grands
mesure on doit tout à fait reconnaître
qu' on doit
suivre tous les appels à l'action de
l'activité de
réconciliation et vérité on doit arrêter
des possibles des enfants autochtones
donc on doit faire beaucoup de choses
mais cet état profond c'est vraiment
quelque chose qu'on doit faire aussi
merci madame paule à vous la parole oui
merci beaucoup monsieur simon pour à
votre question et comme quelqu'un qui
fait partie d'une diaspora où nous avons
perdu toute notre culture et tous nos
langues à jeu je reconnais sincèrement
l'importance à de garder les longues
alors absolument a en fait j'hésite même
de commenter parce que je cherche à
toujours de donner notre plateforme à au
leadership okten pourparlers pour
eux-mêmes et moi je j'espère un jour
qu'un de nos partis à avoir moins chères
femmes provenant d'une de nos premières
nations précisément parce que c'est le
moment d'avoir ce leadership ah oui
absolument nous sommes à des alliés pour
la souveraineté le l'engagement nation à
nation et de notre détermination
merci madame paule monsieur au tour en
terminant merci monsieur simon gouache
la réconciliation est une priorité pour
tous les chefs sur le plateau ce soir ma
première question dans la chambre de
communes comme chef de l'opposition
était sur la réconciliation
et on doit agir sur les heppell d'action
dans le rapport de la réconciliation la
vérité et je vais agir sur les langues
on doit livrer les survie ce spécifiques
dans les langues additionally line up
stockton et il y a deux semaines on
annoncé un investissement historique
dans la santé mentale à des autochtones
aux les services dont les langues
traditionnelles avec un archet
deviennent
autochtone mais surtout est ce qu'elles
devraient être reconnus officiellement
comme langue officielle hina jilali
nationale maintenant mais c'est possible
d'avoir des services dans les langues
autochtones
merci messieurs simon merci beaucoup
d'avoir pris la parole ce soir c'était
courageux et et locales merci beaucoup
en avant soirée merci monsieur simon
nous allons faire deux blocs de cinq
minutes où je veux ouvrir les micros à
tout le monde sur cette question là
parce que c'est important puis je veux
pour faire d'allées et venues je veux
qu'on soit le plus clair possible pour
le téléspectateur je vais vous demander
de nous parler de deux éléments
importants lots dans les réserves et la
question du territoire la crise de oued
souf des watts ou et elle n'est pas très
lointaine même si ça me paraît très loin
contenu de la pandémie monsieur singh au
pot table le hasard a voulu on commence
avec vous au potable la vérificatrice
générale a encore dit ce n'est pas réglé
oui il ya eu de l'argent mais ce n'est
pas réglé qu'est ce que vous faites pour
aider à régler ce problème dans les
réserves vous avez dit monsieur singh
mais regardez excusez moi je suis parti
parce que tout n'est pas rose de froid
je suis content je suis cette année je
suis d'accord avec monsieur
merci mais mais j'ai plaisanté un peu
mais c'est une honte je t'aime mon
sérieux et ici je dois dire clairement
que dans un pays assez riche que le
nôtre c'est vraiment inexcusable que
toutes les communautés autochtones ont
pas accès à l'eau potable donc dans mon
avis ce n'est pas en question des
capacités
compétences c'est vraiment question de
volonté donc quand monsieur trudeau a vu
deux premières semaines de cette
pandémie la sautée pour donner 750
milliards de dollars de baxter pour les
grandes banques mais elle a brisé sa
promesse de livrer l'eau potable donc je
ne les accepte pas que c'était un manque
de capacité c'était un manque de volonté
et c'est c'est vraiment une honte une
honte la vérificatrice générale monsieur
trudeau part d'une formule de
financement 18 c c'est un rapport de
qu'il ya quelques mois ça fait des
décennies que on à ce défi d'eau potable
sûre dans les communautés autochtones et
c'est pour ça qu'on a fait la promesse
d'en finir partout au pays on en en
éliminer 109 il nous en reste une couple
douzaine à 50 à peu prêt à continuer on
est en train de travailler activement
dans chaque communauté on a un plan on a
un préposé un représentant qui fait le
travail au vol arrivé oui la pandémie
nous a retardé un petit peu mais c'est
pas des excuses on va finir ce travail
mais c'est au tour parler - là c'est à
vous oui monsieur trudeau a brisé ses
promesses sur l'eau potable et la
réconciliation c'est sur la confiance
entre les premières nations et le
gouvernement fédéral c'est pourquoi
c'est très important d'avoir un plein
page des belles paroles on doit livrer
parce que l'eau potable sur la réserve
est un doigt on doit livrer avec une
partenariat avec les dirigeants
autochtones les entreprises optent
octobre et je vais créer un plein de
livres et en partenariat madame paule
oui encore je parle directement canadien
canadian et jeudi à que cette exaction
exactement pour ça que nous avons besoin
de plus de diversité dans notre avis
politique parce que s'il ya aura par
exemple plus de gens qui ont eu
l'expérience de vivre son eau potable ce
serait un plus grand creux et est ce qui
manque c'est que le volonté rien de plus
à notre investissement dans l'oléoduc
atm ex coûte beaucoup mieux que de payer
pour de l'eau potable dans chaque crime
c'est octobre
on a le droit d'évaluer un gouvernement
au résultat qu'il livre on a un
gouvernement qui lorsqu'il le jugera
nécessaire
avec l'appui de la chambre des communes
qu'il aurait d'ailleurs dans le dossier
de l'eau pour les communautés
autochtones qui a trouvé le manière de
déployer des centaines de milliards de
dollars pourtant après toutes ces années
là il n'a pas trouvé les moyens de
déployer rapidement les ressources
financières humaines et en
infrastructures pour qu'il y ait de
l'eau sur des communautés autochtones
sous sa juridiction fédérale c'est une
honte à l'échelle internationale il faut
au delà des engagements électoraux que
tout le monde dise une même voix on va
voter pour ce soit réglé maintenant à la
satisfaction des communautés autochtones
touchées on aimerait lors du prochain
débat des chefs ne pas avoir à poser la
question en effet effectivement les
territoires les chemins de fer ont été
bloqués au canada monsieur tour d'où
est-ce que ça avance et cette
négociation oui ça avance et ce avant
c'est parce qu'on a justement résisté
aux appels des conservateurs et d'autres
d'envoyer l'armée d'envoyer la police de
passer le temps en négociations ça pris
quelques jours de plus mais oui même
pendant cette crise qui a duré plusieurs
jours plus qu'une semaine on a pu le
régler de façon paisible de façon
harmonieuse et on continue de travailler
main dans la main en partenariat dans le
respect c'est la seule façon merci
l'agencé on va reparler dans l'autre
bloc de cette question de territoire et
d'autres questions jacquin guillaume
bourgault-côté de l'actualité pour poser
ses questions bonsoir à tous monsieur
août où la barre parlons culture vous
promettez de reprendre à zéro le projet
de loi sur les géants du web comme
netflix spotify et vous êtes aussi que
vous voulez que les plateformes
numériques réinvestissent une part
considérable de leur revenu pour
financer des séries des films ou la
musique canadienne j'aimerais savoir une
part considérable
ça veut dire plus ou moins que les 830
millions millions que les libéraux pro
mais je suis fier de nos artistes
québécois canadiens et les créateurs de
contenu et on doit y culebra le train
entre les géants du web tout en
respectant nos valeurs et la liberté
d'expression c'est pourquoi on va à
travailler avec les secteurs portugal
pour protéger notre notre économie est
d'aider nos artistes tout en respectant
la liberté d'expression sassard et notre
approche avez vous une cible financière
sur le montant que vous voulez aller
chercher auprès des géants du web on va
aider les sectes le plus touché par la
pandémie particulièrement les artistes
les musiciens on doit aider les artistes
en crise maintenant c'est une part de
notre plan de rétablissement du canada
madame paule le français la langue
officielle du québec bien sûr pourquoi
il dit et vous devant l'idée que ce soit
reconnu dans la constitution canadienne
comme le prévoit la réforme de la loi
101 par le gouvernement le goût à québec
mais je n'hésite pas de tout à mes deux
enfants font partie de la francophonie à
ma mère a fait d énormes efforts que je
sois bilingue l'effet des trajets trajet
de 1h30 en chacun direction am c'est
très important de protéger le français
c'est très important est de renforcer le
français a et malheureusement ça devient
quasi impossible de recevoir une
éducation bilingue à alain traoré nada
je vous parle d'inscrire le français
comme langue officielle du québec dans
la constitution mais j'ai pas dit ça du
tout ah si vous parlez de lââm le projet
de loi 96 ce que j'ai dit c'est qu'il y
a des questions à constitutionnel qui
sont soulevées il faut les examiner
c'est tout mais sur le fond dont vous
n'avez pas de problème avec ça
gg comme j'ai pas du tout d'accord je
suis monsieur singh où vous dénoncez le
québec bashing mais lorsqu'un nouveau
député a appuyé les propos d'un
professeur qui dit que la culture du
québec est raciste vous ne le vous
laisser aller
qu'est ce que vous dites ou québécois
qui ont l'impression que sur cet enjeu
là il est un peu une chose et son
contraire pas d'études de cas c'est faux
j'ai toujours dit que je suis content du
québec bashing tu nous débiter ils sont
contre le québec bashing et on a dit que
cette sorte de discrimination systémique
n'a aucune place dans notre société on
est contre ça on va toujours être un
allié pour les québec pour défendre la
langue française pour défendre les
intérêts du québec c'est quelque chose
que tu cherches d'accord parce que
c'était nos valeurs jack layton a
commencé avec la d re création de
sherbrooke et on continue ça et pourquoi
profondément que de québec a le droit de
retrait avec pleine compensation dans
chaque programme fédéral mais pourquoi
on continue de la prise ne pas avoir
rappelé à l'ordre votre député s'est
associé à du québec balle j'ai parlé
avec mon député est hilare et finissons
en erreur et on continue de dire
clairement qu on est un party in alliés
du québec merci monsieur blanchet le
programme de contestation judiciaire
aide à défendre les droits des minorités
comme on l'a vu avec les francophones et
l'hôpital montfort vous demandez que le
prochain gouvernement intervienne dans
la gestion de ce programme indépendant
pour dire ne touchez pas à la loi sur la
laïcité
êtes vous d'accord avec une intervention
politique de ce type là seulement quand
ça fait votre affaire de se blanchir
battu à répéter ce que j'ai dit en point
de presse hier dans un premier temps le
bloc a toujours été en faveur du
programme de contestation judiciaire
cependant le gouvernement le confie à
une institution qui en a fait une arme
politique contre les valeurs québécoises
soutenant ce qui rompt contre la loi 21
sur la laïcité ou compte éventuelle loi
96 et ça c'est très problématique dans
une institution qui a fait taire une
professeure et qui laisse allègrement
parler le professeur atta rend à qui
personne ne fait de reproche au npd est
d'ailleurs en passant jeudi soit le
ministre assume son programme le futur
ministre ou soit le ministre change de
modèle de gouvernance que ça reste
indépendant mais qui se soit pas confiée
à une institution qui systématiquement
va s'en prendre au québec sur le fond
rapidement des minorités du québec elles
ont donc le droit pour vous peut-être de
voir leur recours financiers lorsqu'ils
veulent contester des lois une sacrée
différence en dire on va donner 250
mettait sa commission scolaire
anglophone de montréal qui est pas dans
le rouge financièrement pour aller
contester une loi du québec alors que la
juridiction est une juridiction
québécoise penser en effet à l'hôpital
montfort et aux francophones hors québec
merci monsieur trudeau ça fait quatre
ans quatre ans que vous promettez que
les géants du web vont finir par
financer le contenu culturel canadien
vous aviez pourtant rien que changé en
quatre ans a dit un projet de loi là
dessus j'ai pas été adoptée précisément
parce que vous vous avez déclenché des
élections êtes vous sérieux monsieur
trudeau dans cette démarche je pense que
les artistes au québec qui a partout à
travers le pays savent à quel point on
était là pour pendant cette pandémie
mais aussi avant cette pandémie on a
renversé la tendance horrible du
gouvernement conservateur à d'avant de
toujours s'attaquer aux artistes on a
été là pour radio canada on était là
pour nos artistes on a continué
d'assurer que oui des géants comme
netflix investissent plus au québec et
d'ailleurs on est en train de travailler
avec la communauté internationale pour
s'assurer que tout le monde paie sa
juste part en terme d'impôts nous avons
mis de l'avant le projet s'est dit ce
qui a tardé en grande partie à cause des
conservateurs mais les autres partis
n'étaient pas toujours prêts à le
prioriser comme on aurait voulu on a été
là pour les artistes on va continuer de
l'être merci merci beaucoup merci
guillaume tour de table il ya eu un
article de thomas gerber du canada qui a
étonné et choqué beaucoup de gens hier
au nom de la réconciliation
une commission scolaire en ontario a
brûlé des livres
tour de table et lazard fait que je
conseille monsieur blanchet est ce qu un
leader doit avoir une position claire
devant ce genre de choses évidemment je
le dis je suis assez satisfait parce que
les interventions que j'ai fait hier cet
égard là que ce soit la commission
scolaire anglophone de montréal que dix
jeux devraient reconnaître la nation
québécoise où le conseil scolaire de
présidence jeudi boli délit n'était pas
une bonne idée tout le monde est
adéquatement reculer c'est apaisant moi
ça me convient personnellement je voue
un culte où les gens n'accumule bien
plus que je n'irai jamais dans ma vie et
je pense qu'il faut avoir le courage
d'être confrontés à ceux qui dans notre
passé et dans notre littérature et dans
la littérature monde est mondiale pardon
ne dit pas ce qu'on veut que ça disent
de telle sorte qu'on pourrait
l'expliquer le présenter l'enseigné et
préparer les jeunes et le futur à de
meilleures valeurs sûres trudeau est ce
que c'était pas votre devoir comme
leader hier matin et d'énoncer
clairement parce qu'au nom de la
réconciliation
on peut pas tout faire non plus tout à
fait et j'ai dit clairement que c'est
inacceptable de brûler des livres en
même temps nous n'allons pas dire au
peuple autochtone comment ils doivent se
sentir et trouver cet équilibre c'est
très important
le brûlage des livres est toujours
inacceptable dans une société comme
notre société et on doit cibler sur la
réconciliation sont les étapes sont les
gestes comme ça alain bolle que vous en
pensez vous oui bon d'abord hier c'était
un festival une fête juive et je suis
juif je n'étais pas au courant jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
absolument lci à des meilleures façons
de s'exprimer à mais de l'autre côté on
sait qu'il ya beaucoup de frustration à
don le don les communautés autochtones à
dont les communautés noires aussi à caen
on attend pour des décennies pour
l'action sur la justice criminelle sur
la réconciliation à on devient frustrés
et c'est le moment pour l'action alors
j'espère que nous pouvons trouver des
réseaux plus productive à mais il faut
trouver des solutions
si je peux bien sûr c'est que je suis
entend tout le monde je ne pense pas au
début les délices et des monnaies dit
pas du tout je pense qu'on doit garder
l'histoire est de savoir c'était quoi
les choses que les gens ont fait dans la
passé et je comprends
profondément comment les peuples
autochtones on est de la misère avec
comment les gens on était à prix de
leurs coutures comment on est saine leur
culture dans mon enfance ce que j'ai
appris neyret ne respect pas la dignité
et les contributions et les
connaissances de peuples autochtones
donc on doit avoir une conversation
sérieuse sur comment on doit enseigner
enseigner les contributions des peuples
autochtones hui cette dame qui a proposé
sur monsieur trudeau est lé ter ou parti
libéral du canada à la commission de
réconciliation elle ne l'est plus c'est
une bénévole qui a qui s'est retiré de
sa position et qui se dit autochtone et
qui ne l'était pas c'est sa boule qui
peut avoir d'aidé avec trop de bons
sentiments
je ferai toujours attention quand on
contredit où on prend des décisions
selon laquelle quelqu'un s'identifier ou
non une communauté particulière faut
laisser beaucoup d espace pour pour
l'identité personnelle je peux en train
de défendre le geste mais je veux que
tout le monde fasse attention en
conclusion le rapidement que d'aucuns
dit faut pas dire au peuple autochtone
quoi faire et quoi penser mais s'il faut
pas dire ou nation autochtone quoi faire
ou quoi penser pourquoi dit-il à la
nation québécoise quoi faire et quoi
penser parce que je suis québécois
monsieur blanche est un
atout angie je suis fier québécois que
j'ai toujours été québécois que je serai
toujours québécois et je suis là avec
mon mot à dire vous avez pas
l'unanimité sur sur le québec on est
plusieurs à représenter la chambre va
même si je peux vous dire monsieur
blanche est une matrice de 12 des
blanchettes que vous ne voulez pas
s'aimer les gérants tu fais les âges au
québec prenez le bilan du gouvernement
comme étant le vôtre si des
contradictions profondes mais non vous
maîtriserez pas d'être pro québécois
monsieur blanchet la démocratie céder
quoi québécoise s'exprime à l'assemblée
nationale
gouverneur il aura pas de quelque chose
mais sur la volonté de l'assemblée
nationale du québec en matière de langue
est très bien monsieur du plancher
surtout rapidement 20 c'est le seul chef
qui peut remplacer résultant de calais
on a su tisser sa et un doigt les
québécois et les québécoises on doit
agir pour vaincre très bien passé comme
ça des salins mais ce n'est pas le gars
si monsieur singh il faut aulas et
prochains temps
[Musique]
justice et affaires étrangères noémie on
à une question du public fait
l'opération d'évacuation en afghanistan
a pris fin dans le chao encore
aujourd'hui à 1250 ressortissants
canadiens et membres de leurs familles
qui sont coincés là bas un nombre auquel
il faut ajouter presque dix mille
afghans qui ont collaboré avec les
forces canadiennes et qui craignent pour
leur vie maintenant que les talibans ont
repris le pouvoir catherine bosc et la
soeur de la capitaine nichola goddard de
tués au combat en 2006 à kandahar on la
retrouve à vancouver bonsoir madame rask
bonsoir alors vous avez fondé un
organisme qui vient en aide à ces civils
afghans d'ailleurs vous essayez de faire
venir l'interprète qui a travaillé avec
votre char on vous écoute quelle
question voulez vous posez au cher ce
soir
le canada a beaucoup trop tardé à agir
pour ma soeur la chose la plus
importante était sa responsabilité
envers son équipe et pour elle les
interprètes faisons partie de l'équipe
elle n'aurait jamais voulu qu'on les
abandonne
qu'allez vous faire pour évacuer les
canadiens et les interprètes afghans qui
ont été laissées derrière merci beaucoup
pour cette question en amoureuse que
madame paule à vous la parole merci
beaucoup pour la question et à judy
sincèrement d'abord je n'aurais jamais
déclencher une élection à qu'on nous
avait à des canadiens canadiennes et les
aléas personnes qui nous on a soutenu à
prendre dans notre mission en
afghanistan
j'avais déjà à demander à tous les chefs
des autres partis de participer dans un
débat d'urgence mais vous êtes tout à
fait correct le canada doit droit à me
respecter alors nos promesses leurs
promesses il faut le faire sinon elles
ne seront pas des alliés sinon nous
n'aurons pas de partenaire international
alors maintenant c'est le moment de
concentrer sur l'évacuation à de nos
citoyens citoyennes et aussi ceux qui
nous ont aidés merci monsieur singh un
merci madame race des mercis pour les
services de votre famille c'est c'est
vraiment incroyable en cible ce qui
s'est passé de fait que nos ailiers qui
ont mettre leur vie en péril pour aider
nos forces canadiens étaient laissés
derrière
c'est c'est vraiment
inacceptable que ce s'est passé comme ça
et on a vu des images de ce qui s'est
passé en invitant les stands c'est une
tragédie des droits de la personne ni
lésions sur menace et ont péri de perdre
leur vie donc je suis d'accord avec
madame apporte que on ne jamais auraient
dû déclencher une élection et maintenant
on doit faire sur tout ce qu'on peut le
sauver les vies de nos alliés merci
monsieur o toole merci pour la question
madame la situation en afghanistan est
très très haut les femmes et les filles
là bas mais aussi pour nos familles
militaires et nos anciens combattants et
malheureusement mais surtout dos a
abandonné les traducteurs les
travailleurs sur le terrain là-bas et
malheureusement les il ya des mois nos
vétérans ont
demandé un plan d'action sur
l'afghanistan
mais messieurs to do à déclencher une
élection à il a ignoré le problème et
comme d'habitude ils étaient là comme un
ancien combattant moi même je vais agir
dans nos intérêts chez nous et à travers
le monde merci monsieur trudeau mais
l'amour je comprends ta peine et même ta
frustration
les canadiens ont fait énormément de
sacrifices pour améliorer le sort des
femmes des filles du peuple afghan votre
famille à sacrifier plus qu'elle
n'aurait jamais dû avoir à sacrifier et
donc je comprends la peine que vous avez
et le désir de tous les canadiens de
continuer à aider en afghanistan c'est
ce qu'on va faire oui on a agi
rapidement dès le début on a commencé
des vols d'évacuation n'avait que est
évacué à 3700 personnes beaucoup plus
que certains nos alliés en europe mais
nous devons continuer d'être là pour se
faire sortir non seulement les canadiens
qui restent mais des dizaines de
milliers de gens de plus que nous allons
amener accueillir chez les canadiens ici
la nouvelle vaucher eux mais c'est
blanche et que devons-nous faire madame
ross
d'abord il faut reconnaître que le
canada n'est pas une puissance
internationale
c'est problématique parce que ça fait
que le canada ne peut pas agir autrement
qu'en coordination avec des ali et la
crédibilité canadienne dans les
dernières sérieusement été abîmée la
relation avec la chine la relation même
avec les états unis récemment l'arabie
saoudite qui est un exemple pitoyable du
comportement canadien il faut avoir une
alliance solide avec des alliés il ya 90
pays qui ont dit qu'il ne reconnaît être
épaules régime taliban et qui sont prêts
à exercer des pressions il n'y a que des
pressions coordonnées qui feront en
sorte que les taux des talibans sur les
interprètes et sur possiblement encore
des ressortissants étrangers se
relâcheront un peu c'est la seule
solution
d'avoir porté ce message parmi nous ce
soir à bientôt merci madame ross
vraiment merci j'appelle marie vastel du
devoir à venir poser ses questions ou
chef
bonsoir monsieur blanchet
en matière d'immigration vous voulez
privilégier l'accueil de réfugiés de
langue française au québec mais on sait
que la majorité des réfugiés ne parle
pas français quand ils sont à l'étranger
donc qu'est ce que vous feriez avec je
mettrai une petite nuance je veux que le
canada rétablisse et 16,2 pénalisé par
exemple les étudiants francophones
étrangers qui veulent venir ici ceux qui
viennent d'afrique se font refuser à 80%
et ils sont francophones et ils veulent
venir au québec c'est donc une espèce de
discrimination administrative qui nie
beaucoup aux français pour ce qui est de
l'accueil de réfugiés l'accueil des
migrants comme j'ai eu l'occasion de
dire à plusieurs occasions moi je suis
dessus qui sont réouverts açores mais
vote sous les halles de la capacité de
francisation mais votre attente par
d'accueil de réfugiés de langue
française est-ce que ça et qui voit ce
qu'est le québec accueille moins que sa
femme ça veut dire qu'on fait tout ce
qu'on peut pour qu'un maximum soit
francophone c'est ce que les québécois
souhaitent savait pas et comprend pas
nos responsabilités ou de dessau et l'on
revient toujours aux mêmes enjeux en
matière d'immigration qu'est-ce qu'on
peut déployer comme ressource pour
franciser ceux qui viennent vivre au
québec et devenir qui merci monsieur
c'est un bon soir vous voulez devenir
premier ministre d'un pays du g7 mais
votre plateforme électorale contient à
peine quelques idées générale sur la
politique étrangère selon vous quelle
devrait être alors le premier geste du
prochain gouvernement ainsi on perdait
ce qu'on peut faire au niveau mondial
mais surtout nous a dit que le canada
arrive encore mais à ce moment notre
niveau ces investissements tout pour le
développement économique est tellement
bas à ce n'est pas au niveau qu'on doit
avoir comme un pays g7 donc on va tout
de suite augmenté sa et aussi de
rapporter notre notre position comme un
pays de diplomatie de respecter la paix
un pays qui défend les intérêts de
droits de la personne avec d'hébron des
bons actions concrètes pour le faire et
sur la chine très rapidement vous parlez
de données tenir tête à la chine ça veut
dire quoi de différent monsieur trudeau
donc le grand différence est qu'on a on
avait eu une voté pour reconnaître le
génocide contre les huit coeurs monsieur
trudeau a n'était pas dans la chambre
même tout c'est son cabinet n'était pas
là donc ça montre montali le chemin si
monsieur trudeau justement on ne voit
même pas consulté quand le président
américain a décidé que les états unis
maintiendraient
la frontière fermée aux canadiens
comment pouvez vous défendre les
intérêts du pays si vous n'êtes même pas
capable de parler directement à joe
biden quand ça compte
au contraire mari j'ai parlé souvent au
président bas et deviennent au niveau de
nos frontières pour le coordonnées le
plus possible mais c'est pas aux états
unis de nous dire comment gérer nos
frontières une autre population c'est
pas nous non plus de dire aux américains
comment le gérer mais je soulignerai que
pendant toute cette pandémie les
canadiens étaient libres de prendre un
vol jusqu'en floride qui soient
vaccinées ou non s'est il ya eu une
asymétrie dès le début quand nous avons
mis des mesures de quarantaine
obligatoire que les américains n'avaient
pas ce qui a trait à votre relation avec
monsieur byden ya seulement eu trois
at-elle dit latéraux est ce que monsieur
badin vous oublier au contraire on a
passé justement une journée entière en
discussion dès son arrivée c'était une
de ces premières rencontres pour établir
justement le parcours que nous allions
prendre ensemble
les relations avec les etats-unis sont
très bas madame paule la question
israélienne a failli faire imploser
votre parti récemment contrairement à
vous vos militants un pro de la ligne
dure face à israël est ce que vous vous
êtes réconcilie avec votre parti depuis
et vous quelle position défendez-vous
d'abord je n'accepte pas cette
formulation de la question a le parti
vert est parti de non-violence à de
dialogue de réconciliation à on applique
ça donne tout les situations à nous
sommes aussi un parti à qui accroît dans
le droit international moi en tant que
ancien diplomate pour notre pays en tant
que grand sérieuse à la cour pénale
internationale
ah je suis quelqu'un qui a qui suit le
droit sert israel madame paul g parce
que votre position n'est pas dans la
plateforme pouvez vous nous dire quelle
est la position stricte nous n'avons pas
une position sont au coeur à enjeu à un
conflit international dans notre patron
alors ok d'abonder nous avons des règles
des principes et général et on lapide en
tout les situations merci monsieur otto
sur la chine pour terminer vous dit que
vous auriez une attitude plus dure que
monsieur trudeau mais même nos alliés ne
vont pas aussi loin que ce que vous
proposez est ce que vous ne craignez pas
du coup plus de sanctions économiques et
d'autres canadiens qui vont être pris en
otage nous on doit avoir une approche
plus sérieux en cycle qu'une seule
machine mais surtout d'eau était
toujours dehors de la ligne avec la
chine petit clément avec la le génocide
à il a manqué le vote sur le génocide en
chine nos alliés sont apposés huawei
dans notre système de 5g nous sommes le
seul pays dans les cinq yeux en faveur
de huawei on doit y couler brel de train
sur le commerce international pour les
sciers et l'aluminium mais je suis obama
a commencé ça met tout le temps mais
surtout d'eau était lent mais on en a vu
des sanctions dans nos vues des
représailles et ce qui n'aurait pas plus
avec ce que vous dites on doit défendre
nos valeurs
et nos citoyens et les sanctions mode
big band qui sont très important
d'agir contre le parti communiste
chinois très bien merci beaucoup merci
marie le temps file débats ouverts
finale madame messieurs ça va aller vite
les armes à feu la mairesse de montréal
accompagné d'autres mais régis la bombe
se sont dit extrêmement inquiet hier
madame plan dit on se dirige vers une
société à l'américaine usage des armes à
feu devient banal n'attendons pas a dit
monsieur la bombe que ça devienne le
wild west au pays les armes qui ont été
interdites par monsieur trudeau surtout
est ce que vous voulez vous allez les
gars des interdits pour tout votre monde
je vais maintenir les restrictions en
place pour les armes à feu et je vais
enlever la politique sur le système et
les maires son corps est on doit cibler
les gangs de rue et les 80 on a un plan
de faire ça en est qu un toit
collaboration avec les policiers les
municipalités parce qu'on a vu des
fusillades à montréal avant gravats avec
des armes parce que j'avais changé votre
programme à trois reprises aux éditions
1 à prologue à l'est et transparent
c'est parce que on doit enlever la
politique monsieur la chaîne reçu des
impôts j'ai un plan j'ai un contrat une
fois qu'il signe et je vois le changer
je suis un nouveau chef dans un nouveau
parti avec les mêmes résultats là vous
pourriez utiliser le mot flou c'est
absolument pas clair ou moins les
libéraux ont fini par accepter la
contrainte dans le rachat des armes
d'assaut il faut aller et le bloc les on
a même rendre ce plus sévères quand j'ai
rencontré mandant plantes armes d'assaut
arme de poing interdiction faut modifier
le code pénal donner les outils à québec
donné les outils aux corps policiers il
faut éradiquer ce danger qui rend les
rues de montréal qui transforme les rues
de montréal en champ de bataille de
gagne 2 rue et de crime organisé sur
trudeau
pour les armes de poing les maires
depuis des années vous disent on ne nous
donne pas à pas dans notre cour
occupez-vous de sa interdisez partout
d'abord les gens savent très bien on a
toujours été là pour renforcer le
contrôle des armes à feu et on va
continuer de l'être et oui on a affaire
au maire à travers le pays la
possibilité d'interdire leur arme de
poing sur leur territoire est maintenant
on va donner aux provinces qui le
veulent comme le québec l'interdiction a
des armes de poing sur leur territoire
mais je pense que il ya ici un élément
de leadership extrêmement important où
monsieur o'toole a refusé de dire aux
québécois qu'est ce qu'ils voulaient
faire a refusé de dire aux canadiens ce
qu'il voulait faire il fait des deals
avec des groupes d'intérêts spéciaux
quand le fait sur les vaccins comme il
le fait a dit soi disant pro choix mais
80 de ses députés ont voté contre
l'avortement à compte le choix des
femmes il le fait sur le climat en rock
rock revenons en arrière sur monsieur
harper c'est du leadership mookie
l'offre et même avec sa plateforme enfin
chiffrées ont retenu le temps l'entrée
des vestiaires priorités des canadiens
ne
peut pas être cru là dessus monsieur
trudeau dira ne porte quoi on gagne je
suis pro choix je vais agir sur le
sécurité publique parce que on a vu une
augmentation des fusillades à cause des
les armes à feu et lio on a vu une
augmentation de la contrebande à la
frontière on a vu des travailleurs
illégaux araxxe ont droit voire
n'approche sérieuses et la sécurité
c'est un leader au choix que de suivre
ses députés ces députés il suit en crise
il est suivi sur les vaccins donnés
enfin quand
ses propres députés c'est pourtant du
déjeuner monsieur automne
c'est pareil au même il sait des vieux
parti qui parle comme ça on aime en
option dans cette élection monsieur
trudeau a promis d'avoir un rachat
obligatoire il a brisé sa promesse donc
ça monte encore exactement monsieur
brice et promesses comment les gens
peuvent croire et à ce moment je dis
clairement à pour l'avenir on ne peut
pas se permettre quatre ans de plus
c'est cette approche de dire grand-chose
à faire autre chose fait des grands
promesses et puis les prises d c'est sur
ces comptes il est bien sûr je vous
permets pas la luge sur les armes à feu
pour moi d'abord j'ai rentré dans la vie
politique sincèrement pour nom la
politique et pas pour annuler à partir
de la bi partisan âme si on parle des
armes à feu des armes d'assaut
absolument il faut abolir la position
d'eads ead est deux à il faut respecter
les maires à mais aussi il faut attaquer
les racines auxquelles inégalités le
manque de d'abord de logements
abordables à les choses qui provoque
canaux les crimes à dans le dans le
premier instance c'est ça vraiment
est-ce qu'on va attaquer les racines est
ce qu'on va changer les choses où est ce
qu'on va continuer avec un traitement
destine comme très bien alors tout le
monde s'est exprimé tout le monde s'est
exprimé sur les armes à feu je m'en
voudrais de ne pas vous poser une
question même s'il nous reste peu de
temps sur les francophones qui vivent
dans une situation de communautés
minoritaires
allez vous aider par exemple qu'un peu
singes en alberta l'inversé de sebring
verser de monde jeunes qui sont
vulnérables devant les coupes des
provinces tour de table dans ce sens là
monsieur autour oui on a un fond d'un
autre plan d'aidé les communautés
minoritaires francophones de notions et
l'autre c'est une force pour notre pays
et ont en plus on va moderniser la loi
sur les langues spéciale après six ans
d'inaction avec miss you to do les
communautés francophones au québec mais
attention 20 secondes chaque membre
donne une version peu saint-jean
universités francophones de l'ontario
c'est des policiers conservateur qui
coupent dans les langues minoritaires
coupe pour les communautés séparées un
auto en face de john ford enfin jack
isaac a dit en face de blaine higgs qui
va être l'heure pour les communautés
francophones nous le serons toujours une
bonne en tant que mère de deux fils
francophone je dis oui oui oui pour la
langue française j'adore les français il
faut le protéger il faut assurer que
tout le monde a accès à une éducation
bilingue s'il le veut encore une autre
belle preuve de monsieur trudeau mais
dont sur le terrain à sept bris son
équipe n'était pas là il n'était pas là
pour défendre la langue française pour
défendre ses institutions notre équipe
était là on va toujours défendre les
institutions francophones parce que
c'est ça enrichit notre société la
france est la belle robe molière donne
un des grands avantages en auvergne non
monsieur blanchet conclusion lance je
loue déjà blanche m le bloc québécois
continuera d'être la voix est souvent la
seule voie pour les francophones hors
québec et les acadiens par le parlement
la loi sur les langues officielles
devraient se consacrer exclusivement aux
francophones hors québec le québec peut
gérer ses propres enjeux merci à vous
sec j'espère mesdames et messieurs que
vous n'êtes plus éclairés noémie merci
merci merci pâle questions du public
vraiment fort prédit merci à nos
citoyens d'ailleurs et il n'est donc
c'est un exercice je le dis au début
précieux c'est parfois difficile mais je
pense a été clair alors merci de vos
disciplines ramsey messieurs prochain
rendez vous le jour du vote le 20
septembre aller voter merci bonne fin de
soirée percée à toute l'équipe en régime
sur le plateau
[Musique]
bonsoir dimnet cette édition spéciale de
24,60 nous allons consacrer la prochaine
heure et demie à l'analyse du débat des
chefs qui vient tout juste de se
terminer
j'espère que vous aurez trouvé réponses
à vos questions et nous allons également
vous présenter les points de presse de
chacun des chefs en direct alors cet
affrontement de ce soir at il était un
point tournant dans la campagne le
sera-t-il un chef est il parvenu à se
donner un nouvel élan au moment où les
sondages font état d'une course très
serrée
rien n'est joué encore et sans surprise
de débattre ce soir a donné liban
quelques petites prises de bec mais dans
l'ensemble ce fut un débat très très
civilisé on va connaître les impressions
de nos analystes dans un instant mais
d'abord je jouais ma collègue laurence
martin ottawa bonsoir laurence bonsoir
anne marie à travers cinq jours de
campagne monsieur triaud a encore dû
justifier sa décision de déclencher des
élections en pleine quatrième vague oui
il a souvent été attaqués durant ce
débat par ses adversaires sur cette
question monsieur trudeau qui répète un
peu le même argument le cas des
différences fondamentales entre les
plateformes des partis c'est important
pour les canadiens de s'exprimer
monsieur trudeau aussi qui a attaqué le
chef conservateur en dix ans justement
sur la question de la vaccination le
coeur pour le chef conservateur c'est la
même chose des tests rapides et la
vaccination ça ne devrait pas être le
cas donc eu plusieurs échanges corsés là
dessus je laisse d'ailleurs écouter un
échange entre monsieur trudeau et
monsieur blanchette
tout fait une équivalence entre la
vaccination et le dépistage et c'est pas
du tout la même chose quand tu te fais
testés positifs avec les allégations
mais surtout avec le virus et demi
pourquoi plutôt que de répondre par de
l'information par de l'éducation par une
incitation à aller tout le monde se
faire vacciner on est dans un espèce de
d'affrontements qui ne sert absolument
désolé
donc sur la question dès 6h et le cld
monsieur blanchet de ces faits rappelé
durant le débat qu'il y avait eu plus de
morts liées à la copie au québec dans
les autres centres de soins longue durée
au pays donc on lui a dit est ce que ça
ne devrait pas être une excuse pour que
le fédéral s'implique davantage dans la
gestion de la santé des provinces
monsieur blanchette a répliqué en disant
écoutez si on augmente les transferts en
santé les provinces soit capable de
gérer ces centres de soins là comme il
faut et on s'y attendait laurence début
de mois il s'est fait attaqué sur sa
décision d'abolir le programme des
garderies en fait de déchirer l'entente
entre le gouvernement trudeau et les
provinces ta touche le québec
particulièrement ouais ça touche le
québec parce qu'on a appris dans le cas
de financer des conservateurs qui était
dévoilée la cisr ce soir que cette
entente de six milliards de dollars qui
a été conclu entre ottawa et québec le
pour financer davantage de place dans le
réseau des garderies que monsieur toure
n'allait pas respecté cette entente en
fait tu es seulement 600 millions qui
allait transférer vers la province donc
on a de poser des questions ce soir au
chef conservateur il a dit là je vais il
a promis de se coordonner avec le
gouvernement le go sony peau claire non
plus qu'ils veulent faire avec les
autres provinces mais donc monsieur
autour qui était attaqué par ses
adversaires
on peut écouter un échange
on va aider tu les familles québécois
immédiatement et on va aider les
familles à faibles revenus avec une
monte à 2 75% monsieur autour ne
comprend même pas le système de garderie
au québec on a voulu utiliser pour
s'inspirer à travers le pays il dit
qu'il va envoyer un crédit d'impôt aux
familles les plus vulnérables au québec
les prix familles les plus vulnérables
au québec ne paie pas pour leurs
garderies sont mes deux moines city où
les zombies six voix ont laissé une
femme parlé sur mon jeu qui impacte les
femmes plus que les autres
donc des questions importantes sur le
dit un autre enjeu l'environnement et
moi il possible de concilier
environnement économie c'est une
question qui a fait réagir le chef
conservateur est le chef bloquiste ouais
le chef conservateur a une autre qui dit
que c'est possible de réduire nos
émissions tout en soutenant les emplois
entre autres en région il dit que pour
réduire nos émissions on peut par
exemple investir dans les nouvelles
technologies la parler de l'hydrogène
entre autres il a été attaqué par le
chef bloquiste à ce sujet mais monsieur
o'toole a répliqué en disant écoutez
vous monsieur blanchette quand vous
étiez au gouvernement du québec vous
étiez favorable par exemple à
l'exploitation pétrolière sur anticosti
donc ça a donné lieu à un échange musclé
qu'on peut écouter
si possible de réduire les émissions de
gaz et verts tout en créant les emplois
je dois rétablir la confiance dans cet
enjeu mais on a un point de la voiture
du conte de fées va se transformer en
citrouille bientôt il est impossible il
est impossible de réduire nos émissions
de gaz à effet serre en augmentant
l'extraction la production et
l'exportation de pétrole il ya une
manière de faire plusieurs manières de
faire mieux une manière d' exporter ce
savoir ça s'est ressenti plus humaniste
hydrocarbures et les énergies fossiles
sur l'expansion du pipeline trans
pantone c'est une question que notre
collègue patrice thoreau à poser aux
chefs il a demandé quand est ce que ça
va finir en fait est ce qu'il y aurait
une date de péremption pour soyaux qu'un
chef qui était capable d'en donner yeux
tout ça veut dire on leur avait déjà
posé la question et l'émission cinq
chefs une élection c'est très difficile
d'avoir des réponses est bon pour cible
le projet même à sucy nous et qu'elle
évolue et la chose à ce moment là ouais
et bien sûr la question des autochtones
ont été aussi très importante échanges
musclés en dix mètres dos et françois
blanchet oui on est revenue sur cette
question des 5 mai lire leur brûler par
le conseil scolaire providence dans le
sud de l'ontario on a demandé aux chefs
s'il trouvait normal qu'on brûle des
livres comme ça que les écoles brûlent
des livres et ensuite mon bon monsieur
trudeau a dit non mais il a dit il faut
respecter les autochtones on n'est pas
là pour leur dire quoi faire et là
monsieur blanchet été piqué au vif il a
dit mais il a réagi du tac au tac en
disant vous ne devez pas vous donc vous
me suis trop parler au nom des québécois
voici les changes
mais s'il faut poser aux nations
autochtones quoi faire ou quoi penser
pourquoi d'ici là la nation québécoise
quoi faire et quoi penser parce que je
suis québécois monsieur blanchet
je suis fier québécois que j'ai toujours
été québécois que je serai toujours
québécois et je suis là avec mon mot à
dire vous avez pas
l'unanimité sur sur le québec on est
plusieurs à représenter les québécois
même si je peux vous dire monsieur
blanchette faire du matrix de
lenche est que vous ne voulez pas fait
mieux les gérances ce que tu fais les
âges au québec prenez le bilan du
gouvernement comme étant le vôtre c'est
des contradictions profondes mais non
vous me poserez pas d'être québécois
monsieur blanchet
gâchant des échanges les plus musclés de
la soirée ouais est absolument puisse
vous déterminant il a aussi été question
des armes à feu vers la fin du débat
mais ya pas eu de nouveaux engagements
le dollar comme cette campagne crée un
suspense depuis début laurence on va se
demander si cette fois-ci l'éguille va
bouger un frère de l'un ou l'autre des
chefs on n'y trouve que des boss est un
point tournant on va faire m à nos
analystes et au sondage pour mesurer
tout ça dans les prochains jours il en
reste pas beaucoup d'ici le 20 septembre
bonne soit pas cette soirée à vous en
faire ce que vous allez suivre le point
de presse qui s'en vient
merci laurence au revoir
alors 12 analystes sont à nouveau avec
nous je deviens vite et lee jean
christophe bouchet tant d'hommes et
tchad et michel david va venir de
joindre dans quelques minutes jouera
bonsoir à vous alors premiers tours de
piste à vous d'abord le moment fort ce
que vous ce que vous retenez de plus
probant le plus évident depuis
déterminant dans ce dans ce débat de ce
soir geneviève relier ce sera sans doute
l'extrait qu'on a montré à la fin avec
laurence martin ou monsieur trudeau
s'est un peu enflammé avec les charges
avec monsieur blanchet teom je suis
québécois vous pouvez pas m'accuser de
ne pas défendre les intérêts du québec
et c'est à peu près le seul moment où il
ya vraiment eu
un débat ou déclaration de passionnés ça
a été quand même des bornes relativement
calme on avait souvent entendu
l'expression cacophonie pour les débats
précédant les élections pas assez ça n'a
pas été vraiment le cas cette fois ci
donc je sais pas si la fameuse aiguille
il faut bouger ou non ce soir ça a été
relativement
serein jusqu'à un certain point je pas
sûr qu'ils aient eu un job une enquête
mais ça montre est quand même un peu la
passion de monsieur trudeau essayait de
mettre dans le débat mais que les autres
peut être partagé pas autant que lui
mais un des objectifs c'est peut-être
aussi de voir les contrastes les
divergences les oppositions entre les
différents programmes de parti jean
christophe bouchet qu'encore une fois
dans votre région toute la question de
l'environnement et de l'économie très
importante vous votre moment fort de ces
deux heures moi j'ai tout le long du
débat je m'attendais à avoir vraiment un
moment où on pouvait voir une différence
enter parti j'en ai vu trois d'une porte
sur la vaccination il semble assez clair
ici que une part la personne qui est là
- provac sain et monsieur au tour ici on
voit vraiment une position conservatrice
qui ressemble un peu à ce qu'on a dans
l'ouest canadien avec les conséquences
qu'on voit maintenant sur les armes à
feu on va très bien encore ici que
monsieur autour se dégage du consensus
des autres chefs sur les armes d'assaut
oui ou non et le flou et sur les
changements climatiques ici encore on a
vu vraiment une position très centré sur
l'ouest canadien on va mettre l'accent
on va essayer de ménager le secteur
pétrolier est donc dans mon cas moi je
vois vraiment roi du moment important
qui essaie de séparer un peu les
électeurs qui pencherait vers les
libéraux ouvert des conservateurs qu'est
ce que ça va bouger un peu d'après vous
est-ce que ça va influencer parce que le
sondage dont on parlait plus tôt en
soirée 2 j'ai montré qu'il y avait deux
tiers des personnes sondées ne changerai
pas de choix politiques qu'elle est
maintenir l'accès des votes solide et
jean-marc léger nous a déjà dit que à la
dernière élection lors des dernières
élections des gens des x change de les
gens souffrent pour les indécis ils se
décident parfois même dans l'isoloir
alors pour vous et jean christophe
bouchet ça bougera pas beaucoup salon
vous n'avez pas vraiment en fait dans
l'ouest canadien les votes sont à peu
près déjà déterminé on pense que
peut-être une circonscription qui va ou
en alberta qui vont être libéral est
donc dans une large mesure ses positions
lors des conservateurs qui font pas très
bien au québec
ne ne permet pas vraiment d'avoir des
sièges dans l'ouest canadien des de
faire un plein qui est déjà là et donc
c'est une stratégie qui est intéressante
et dans ce contexte là ça aurait été
intéressant de voir comment les gens
vont bouger sur cette version là ici en
fait des conservateurs vont être
capables d'aller rechercher les gens de
la droite qui encensent moment vont vers
le parti populaire et tanda pour vous le
moment fort
ben je me manque plus passionnés c'est
vraiment ce que vous vous avez parlé à
la fin entre monsieur trudeau et
monsieur blanchet sur qui est le voix de
quelqu'un qui exprime la voix du québec
et des québécois mais pour les électeurs
hors québec je pense que il y a eu
d'autres moments où
on pouvait voir comme
comme l'a déjà dit les différences sur
les bacs stinat vaccination obligatoire
ça c'est une chose et puis aussi je
trouve que quand même que c'était sûr on
a passé toute la soirée à parler des
politiques mais qu'est-ce qui étaient
sur la table s'est est question de
crédibilité question de caractère et le
vouloir a livré sur les promesses moi je
trouve que c'est et ça les vrais enjeux
qu qu'on a vu ce soir puisque justement
ils ont passé le test de la crédibilité
on a évoqué je pensais patrice a dû
mentionner mon et sur la question des
armes à feu vous avez changé de position
trois fois sur monsieur trudeau aussi
attaqué sur ses promesses donc compléter
pour mon déclencher des élections qui
pour le test de crédibilité ou le test
d'embauché pour être un outil qui va
gouverner le 21 septembre tanda qui
étaient prêtes à embaucher je dirais sur
le thème de crédibilité sur les armes à
feu par exemple on n'a pas eu de plus de
clapet de monsieur retour ça c'est une
occasion manquée peut-être pour monsieur
trudeau je dirais sur la crédibilité il
y a toujours monsieur singh qui est qui
qui montre ça
il paraît comme quelqu'un qui est
sincère c'est sa sincérité qui qui sort
de l'avant mais lui il a toujours eu des
problèmes et monsieur trudeau a mis le
doigt dessus pour dire que
vous êtes vous n'êtes pas capable de
vous concentrer et de 2,2 m un plan de
l'avant qui va
alors oui je vais aller agen devient
parce que le point de presse monsieur où
tout va se présenter pour le point de
presse dans moins de deux minutes
geneviève sur la performance et on a
parlé des françois blanchet serait
peut-être intéressant de voir comment il
a tiré son épingle du jeu ou pas ce soir
peut-être cuincy qu'il doit être soit
hanté conservateurs ou les libéraux et
pour ce qui est de représenter les
intérêts du québec chance qu'il était
égal à lui-même puis avait fait une
bonne performance assez de passer aux
deux face à face à tva puis encore ce
soir je pense qu'elle fait une solide
performance
le temps était correct on a et abordait
les tous les dossiers à vrai dire je
n'ai pas appris vraiment grand chose de
nouveau je pense qu il répété ce qu'il
avait déjà dit à d'autres occasions il a
bien répété ce qu'on n'a pas beaucoup
entendue par contre aujourd'hui c'est la
question du gouvernement minoritaire on
en a entendu parler un petit peu mais le
bloc québécois finalement c'est ça sa
position c'est à dire mais oui il va y
avoir un gouvernement minoritaire et
c'est grâce à nous lorsque des
gouvernements minoritaires le québec est
mieux desservis je pense que c'était la
chose qu'ils avaient à dire aussi je
voudrais dans l'ensemble un bon débat
pour pour monsieur blanchet parce que
c'était la question de départ de patrice
vous engagez vous a pas de faire un
gouvernement et si vous le faites ça ça
sur quelles bases très rapidement et
escudé surprise quand même est-ce que
quelqu'un ou un argument qui vous a
étonné jean christophe bouchet oui en
fait je suis un spécialiste la politique
étrangère et donc j'ai attendu tout
débat pour avoir le moment ce que moi
j'étais pour trouvé ça intéressant et en
fait ce qui m'a surtout étonné c'est que
c'est monsieur blanchette qui avait à
peu près la meilleure réponse sur la
politique étrangère et qui vraiment au
donner une réponse qui était qu'andré
sur l'afghanistan sur l'importance
d'avoir des partenaires et de faire sans
collaboration et au final je trouve ça
empire unique d'avoir un parti qui est
vraiment un chef de parti qui est
vraiment centriste le québec d'avoir une
vision très le centre est alors monsieur
où tout se présente donc pour son point
de presse on va l'écouter les chaque
fois de 13 jours dix minutes je crois
que ces huit minutes de questions
français de minutes en anglais
bonjour monsieur o'toole louis blouin de
radio-canada dans votre cadeau financier
on constate que vous voulez annuler les
ententes pour le financement des places
en garderie pour les provinces annuler
l'entente avec le québec de 6 milliards
de dollars ma question et les saints
vous dites que vous voulez travailler
vous coordonnez avec monsieur legault il
y aura combien sur la table pour le
québec monsieur retour on va coordonner
avec premiers menacent legault et dans
notre budget on a une plan chiffré pour
ça à part ceux qui ont droit travailler
ensemble sur lagardère et je respecte
les champs de compétence
et en plus on a même approche pour tous
les familles québécoises et petits
quidams on approche juste pour les
familles à faible revenu on va payer
75% donc ça serait une approche de me
faire de réalisme de partenariat
micro du bosphore monsieur o'toole
mélanie tremblay franco presse à la fin
du débat vous avait effleuré la question
de l'éducation post secondaire en
français en milieu minoritaire vous avez
dit que vous avez un plan ce que vous
pouvez aller un peu plus en profondeur
sur qu'est ce que c'est que votre plan
pour l'éducation post secondaire en
français à l'extérieur du québec j'ai
dit que qu'on a un fonde pour les
investissements dans les écoles pour sa
candeur parce que les communautés
francophones hors québec sont très
importants et je suis fier de nos deux
langues nationales j'ai pris mon
français dans les forces armées
canadiennes comme anglophones et on doit
à appuyer nos programmes à travers le
pays c'est pourquoi on va créer un fonds
spécifique pour sa
opérateur nous sommes prêts pour une
question du téléphone
ok
d'ailleurs choisi
on
ne voit pas de question de ce téléphone
nous allons aller dans la salle ici et
nous reviendrons téléphone quelques
instants
avait autant de dépenses que les bureaux
sur cinq ans par votre plateforme bon je
me demandais pourquoi dira t les kiters
conservateur soit 1 fiscale pourquoi
devrait-il vous le soutenir et étant
donné toutes vos dépenses promises
réponse parce que je pense que les
canadiens veulent consommer sont les
raye nous voulons aider les entreprises
qui sont en crise donc dans les années à
venir nous dépensons dans deux domaines
clés pour que les entreprises peut se
reprendre
du fil et surtout dans les secteurs
touchés et aussi en santé donc ce sont
des investissements historiques sans
condition pour les provinces donc nous
priorisons les dépenses et nous avons un
plan pour équilibrer le budget sur dix
ans je suis très fier que nous avons
maintenant le rapport du bureau
parlementaire du budget qui confirme nos
chiffres disent le plan dans lequel en a
besoin pour l'avenir
première question de
la parole
[Musique]
pensez vous que l'immunité collective
devrait mener à une exception en vertu
des restrictions sanitaires
et y at il aussi une exception en vertu
des croyances religieuses réponse j'ai
pas tout entendu votre question mais
moins j'encourage chacun à faire
vacciner j'étais très public à cet égard
nous respectons mais sur les gens à
leurs hôtes ne lui quand alors choix de
santé et ce sera notre approche donc
informé encouragé dans le respect et
nous nous savons de tous les outils que
ce soit les masques ou les tests rapides
en plus de ces seuils de vaccination le
plus élevé possible
question
il ya eu des critiques récentes
décisions anti concurrentielles en
interne est par exemple tout récemment
pour retourner au niveau de 2016 pour
les taux du groupe le cabinet va
peut-être est versée l'addition qu'en
est il pour vous réponse nous voulons
certainement voir plus deux
réseaux rapides zones rurales et nous
voulons avoir plus de compétitions pour
que les prix subissent une pression à la
baisse nous voulons également nous
assurer qu'il n'y ait pas de gens qui
s'accaparent dis-je
secteur spectre donc on veut plus des
compétitions les prix plus bas et avoir
une connectivité rapide 5 1 à 20
l'échéance de monsieur trudeau question
il ya beaucoup de dépenses de santé mais
c'est vers la fin de la décennie que
vous allez surtout dépenses et donc le
système est en difficulté vraiment
malmener le financement est important
maintenant pourquoi reporter toutes ces
dépenses
jusqu'à la dernière mois d'ici la
décennie réponse nous offrons
du financement révisé pour le province
et nous augmentons de 6 % par année donc
à mesure que vous avancez le montant
commence à monter de façon rapide
après quelques amis en plus de cela nous
aurons des investissements dans le
bien-être
mantha les addictions les dépendances
c'est vrai moi je suis vraiment de la
vie qu'il faut soutenir la première
ligne les infirmières et comme monsieur
trudeau s'est trompé ce sont les
provinces qui doivent engager les
infirmières évier bénéfices les préposés
aux bénéficiaires c'est pourquoi nous
allons offrir une augmentation
prévisible sans condition pour remettre
notre système sur les rails après la
pandémie
la prochaine version de pascal gâchette
journal métro à vous la parole
bonjour monsieur tools est alors pendant
les débats vous ne pouvez pas prendre de
risque et vous répéter inlassablement
en plus de ça monsieur triaud pense que
vous n'avez pas de leadership alors
monsieur poulet que vous avez vraiment
la nature du premier livre
répéter la question j'ai un problème
d'entendre
monsieur trudeau vous à ib en disant que
vous n'aviez pas de leadership être que
vous monsieur autour vous devez vraiment
la nature du prochain comme je
suis très expérimentés comme une chef
c'est très important d'avoir les
expériences à j'ai servi 12 ans dans les
forces armées canadiennes à une décennie
dans le secteur privé comme un avocat a
jeté une ministre des anciens
combattants
je suis prêt pour le défi devenu plus
près que monsieur to do on a un plan
aussi le plat pour le rétablissement du
canada et les canadiens et canadiennes
méritent une libraire avec oprah
est maintenant au micro deux
bonjour monsieur autour je vous ai parlé
à vous et à vous plusieurs de vos
candidats à cette élection j'ai posé des
questions et vous m'avez répondu mais
quand votre personnel a découvert que
j'étais avec rebelles nous aimons être
interdits d'entrée est également
incertaine vos candidats se sont enfuis
mois donc gérard deltell ne pensez vous
pas que c'est votre travail de parler à
tous les canadiens et pas seulement
en accord avec vous et que les personnes
que vous aimez
on a un plan d'avoir une campagne trop
suture g10 est temps d'avoir une
approche comme ça à travers le pays
c'est pourquoi chaque jour j'ai une
conférence de presse après mon annonce
c'est pourquoi au début de la campagne
on a lancé notre plateforme et nous
venons de recevoir le rapport de le
directeur parlementaire du budget on
approche de transparence sur notre
couple a essayé c'est important pour moi
comme chef de répondre aux questions
comme ce soit
nos machines étaient venus question vous
avez xixè louis et vers 60 milliards en
santé sur dix ans et pourtant
mon chiffre cela il ya que 3 8 milliards
il sera introduit sur cinq a alors est
ce que c'est juste qu'ils demandent aux
canadiens qui vont recevoir que la
majorité de ce financement si il vous
réalise dans quatre ans réponse que non
parce que ce que les provinces veulent
c'est du financement prévisible long
terme récurrent et sans condition c'est
très important pour les premiers
ministres provinciaux y plus monsieur
leubou y voilà ce qu'on offre aussi pour
ça d'augmentation par année comme
minimum si nous avons de meilleurs
chiffres de croissance économique et ce
sur quoi nous allons plancher ce sera
plus que cela donc cela veut dire que
avec le temps le 6 % à une effet gilles
intérêts composés donc quand vous avez
également toulouse avons des
investissements historiques pour offrir
des services de traitement pour la
montée par exemple des dépendances
pendant la pandémie le troisième pilier
c'est un leadership national sur la
santé mentale donc tous seront longs à
titre de partenaire du finacement près
visé pour les provinces et doute
programmes pour aider notre pays à se
remettre sur les rails
alors en attendant le prochain point de
presse d françois blanchet je vais pas
commenter mes invités sur ce point de
presse du chef conservateur a une autre
je rêve ou d'un match à deux questions
sur les investissements santé et les
deux questions disait une chose à savoir
que l'essentiel la grande part des
investissements santé arriverait à la
fin de la décennie on se demandait
pourquoi et comment se fait-il qu on
promet de dépenser autant presque les
libéraux et comment penser revenir à
liquider budgétaire des questions qui
vont être importants pour vous oui et
moi pour moi c'est la question sur les
transferts sur la santé monsieur o'toole
promis pendant toute sa campagne que
c'est que c'est lui qui va investir dans
les soins de santé mais on voit partir
sa plate forme aujourd'hui et les
chiffres qui ont été attachées avec que
c'est tous vers la fin et puis ce que
les provinces veulent monsieur legault
d'ailleurs c'est non de l'argent d'ici
neuf ans à 10 ans ils veulent tout de
suite une infusion de 28 milliards et
après ça le 6%
alors je sais pas si messieurs au tour
va faire passer ça mais de dire
elle il faut voter pour moi tout de
suite pour que j'ai un mandat et dans
mon deuxième mandat je vais vous donner
vous demandez je sais pas si ça va
passer oui parce que le bitume il ya n'y
a pas de promesses pour ça j'irai vers
20hoo geneviève là dessus sur les
réponses autour ce soir oui je suis
d'accord avec ce que tu as dit magyd ray
par ailleurs qui s'en est quand même
bien tiré parce qu'on ne lui parle plus
de question de la privatisation
c'était un gros morceau il risquait
d'être vraiment talonné sur ce sujet là
il ya une question qui était posée oui
pendant le débat mais
enfin il ya pas de répondre à d'autres
questions alors on écoute monsieur
blanchet je vous reviens
question est activée ou s'il vous plaît
monsieur
laver qui critique ni critiques de
monsieur ou deux quand aux garderies
aujourd'hui il a chiffré six transferts
en santé ce sera moins dans les cinq
premières années que ce qui la laisse
entendre est ce que nous vous est
de l'avis que ce n'est pas ce que vous
lui avez demandé comme qui met à fond ça
c'est exactement le contraire de ce que
nous entendons nous demandons 35%
des coûts du système lui il est à 6 %
par année d'augmentation
donc tout normal
qu'ils maxi système
presque au niveau
qui lui maintenant
toi ni il y a un trou de 28 milliards de
dollars dans sont
donc c'est inacceptable moi j'ai un qui
de savoir ce que sera la réponse du
gouvernement québécois quant aux au
système des garderies et la disparition
soudaine de 6 milliards de dollars pour
le québec
bonjour monsieur blanchet dans le chai
clermont boulet pour un art city médias
une tension vous et monsieur trudeau
durant des balles concernant monsieur
trudeau qui parlait au nom des québécois
ici dit il s'est dit fier québécois n'a
t-il pas le droit de produire des
québécois en tant que québécois il ya
une institution une institution qui
parle au nom des québécois s'appelle
l'assemblée nationale du québec il y
aura 125 élus qui dans un grand nombre
de camps ont adopté à l'unanimité des
propositions ou des motions allant
totalement à l'encontre des positions
monsieur trudeau pas qu'on peut bien
déchirer trois chemises en un débat qui
je suis québécois que je suis avec eux
jusqu'au bout quoi c'est comme quelqu'un
qui se fait ramasser puis qui je suis je
suis innocent je suis innocent approuve
pas grand chose si ce n'est à l'écouté
de ce que québec veut ils vont arrêter
de contester de permettre que soit
contesté ou de financer la contestation
par exemple de la loi 21 qui correspond
à un large consensus au québec ou même
de l'éventuelle loi 96 nous rappelle que
ni lui ni monsieur o'toole ne se sont
engagés à ne pas déférer à la demande de
la commission scolaire anglophone de
montréal l'enjeu de la nation à la cause
suprême où l'enjeu de la langue comme
une langue officielle à la cour suprême
donc on est encore dans ce problème
classique dans un débat des réponses un
peu ambiguë avec plein de grands énoncé
d'intention et très peu de matière
surtout les gens ce qu'ils étaient nuls
moi je voudrais que il ya une
institution qui parmi nous et du québec
à l'assemblée nationale du québec
du québec est souvent voté de façon
unanime afin de promouvoir le canard
québécois jusque contre les positions
adoptées par monsieur trudeau donc il
peut crise est
aussi l québécoise tout comme moi c'est
peut-être vrai mais sur le plan
institutionnel celi lui cela semblait
nationale qui parle c'est avec
ce qu'il ya une question
oui merci la question vient de raymond
scullion
la parole
oui merci
votre sujet de la proposition sur des
garderies dans le seau fils cadet
conservateur
[Musique]
quand j'en ai compte toutes les
affirmations faites par monsieur o'toole
et par monsieur trudeau nous allons
collaborer plus tard maintenant on est
en campagne électorale le lot on peut se
répondent aux questions maintenant on
paie le papa maman surtout quand on est
celui qui a déclenché une campagne
électorale qui a pas été foutu de dépose
un programme avant deux semaines et pour
ce qui me suit où tout le jeu nous
rappelle que dans son programme il ya 6
milliards pour les garderies y aura pas
une scène pour les retraités les années
de plus qu'est ce qui existe maintenant
et il n'y a pas les transferts en santé
demandée par les provinces et le québec
c'est quand même étonnant qu'on réussit
ça qu'on va s'en sortir alors que les
principales dépenses demandées n'existe
même pas dans son plein contre odile
unis la terre
l'auto négocié que personne signé puis
qui change chaque jour
catherine lévesque la presse canadienne
bonjour monsieur blanchet j'aimerais
renchérir sur la question de mon
collègue sur cet échange animé vous avez
vu monsieur trudeau qui arrêté et qu'il
était québécois est ce que vous êtes en
train de suggérer que les québécois
forment un bloc monolithique ils pensent
tous pareils évidemment pas les
québécois votent mais les québécois
votent pour élire le seul parlement qui
ne parle que pour le québec est le seul
parlement qui ne parle que pour le
québec c'est l'assemblée nationale du
québec lieu des québécois qui ont un
ensemble de positions très différentes
les unes des autres sous le charme de la
démocratie mais ça ne permet pas à
quelqu'un qui siège dans un autre
parlement composé à très grande majorité
par des gens qui ne sont pas du québec
évidemment c'est le principe même de
cette étrange chose qu'on appelle le
canada mais il peut poser qui parle pour
le québec houtain qui pesé ou qui peut
pratiquer par l'ontario l'alberta la
colombie-britannique la l'assemblée
nationale du québec parle juste pour le
québec et incidemment le bloc québécois
parlent juste pour le québec ce qui me
permet de ramener le fondement de mon
intervention si c'est bon pour le québec
on se repose si c'est mauvais on se rend
compte et comme on le fait à de
nombreuses reprises on essaiera
d'améliorer les choses pour que ce qui
est adoptée soit bon pour le québec est
dans ce contexte là puisque personne qui
proposera des bonnes choses pour le
québec ne quoi que ce soit à craindre du
bloc québécois qui collaborent quand ces
bons skis haut un de ces deux partis là
qui mérite une majorité
minéraux de souffler
bonjour monsieur blanchet rappelle
pierre aux agences qui est mis je
voulais vous allez parler des langues
officielles vous avez ouvert la porte
avec connaître toutes les langues
autochtones comme des langues
officielles
disons ça ressemblerait à quoi le canada
avec autant de langues officielles
quelle est votre vision souffre et être
détaillé un petit jeu sans aucune
hésitation de la reconnaissance des
langues autochtones sur le territoire
c'est assez précisément ce que jésus sur
le territoire de ce qui s'appelle mal
canada il ya plusieurs nations you la
nation canadienne you la nation
québécoise il ya de nombreuses nations
autochtones chacune des langues
autochtones mérite assurément une forme
de reconnaissance je ne crois pas que le
parlement fédéral puisse ou doivent
demain matin avoir une traduction
simultanée dans chacune des langues du
territoire je ne pense pas ça mais entre
socke et un extrême et continuer à
regarder les langues autochtones
s'étioler
s'effriter comme une peau de chagrin
parce qu'elles ne sont ni reconnu ni
suffisamment soutenue pour qu'elle soit
parler une langue n'existe que quand
elle est parlée que quand elle vit je
pense que des gestes à poser ces gestes
ne doivent pas avec paternalisme
imposé ou suggérés par la tutelle
fédérale mais bien venir des premiers
peuples eux mêmes qu'ils pourront
formuler des demandes par rapport à
commun souhaite que les langues soient
reconnus mise en valeur et là je pense
que comme amis alliés dans une relation
de nation à nation on pourra progresser
de façon très importante
une question ce téléphone souplet
opérateurs espionne question
oui merci la prochaine question et de
olivier daunais
l'écrit à vous la parole
oui bonsoir monsieur blanchet est
tolérée par les d'ebitda francophone
étrangers depuis quelques temps nous
voyons dans les médias des reportages
qui met en avant un retour tant provenir
du gâteau des sujets toiletter canada
quand on a le permis des documents avec
moins de talent appui sera construit
près de plusieurs
changements devraient être faits je
pense qu'il doit y avoir une
accélération du processus de traitement
du doubs si en immigration en général
lorsque les fonctionnaires où le
gouvernement lui même dit on est désolé
on est bord et on n'est pas capable
d'avancer les piles baisse pas on a
évidemment un problème est évidemment
aussi il faut augmenter les ressources
je comprends et je reconnais la
légitimité pour le canada où le québec
de recevoir par exemple des réfugiés
afghans mais il faudra déployer
davantage de ressources pour que
l'ensemble de la machine de traitement
des dossiers d'immigration soit pas
complètement embourbé dans ce contexte
là et je continue a trouvé déplorable
que des étudiants francophones africains
se fasse presque systématiquement on est
dans le 80% refuser leur séjour sur le
territoire pour venir étudier quel
potentiel extraordinaire d'ailleurs
immigration le cocher un que des jeunes
qui viennent s'installer aller chercher
une formation supérieure où viennent
chercher une formation supérieure sur le
territoire québécois peut-être même dans
la perspective de me rit c'est
exactement ce dont on a besoin
nous avons le temps pour une question
rapide de loin sur la chaîne bon soir
louis bouillot et de radio canada est ce
que vous préférez un gouvernement
conservateur ou libéral
tente juste à écouter est ce que je veux
de la tarte aux pommes ou de la tarte au
sucre mais pour l'instant j'ai mieux pas
manger de dessert le fatigue quel que
soit le choix des canadiens moi ma
proposition parce que le bloc si ça sert
le québec sera un bon collaborateur jo
canadiens choisissez votre gouvernement
moi je propose aux québécois un simple
prudence compte tenu de ce qu'on a
entendu que ce gouvernement le soin
minoritaires et ce à peu près tout le
monde au travail qu'à la double québec
les i la route vers un gouvernement
minoritaire c'est un nombre plus élevé
de députés du bloc québécois qui encore
une fois sont de bons collaborateurs
quand c'est bon pour le québec
c'était la dernière question merci
beaucoup
et françois blanchet qui défend son rôle
à ottawa michel david s'est à nouveau
joints à nous avec jeudi intelligent
christophe bouchet et en 2003 alors je
lance la balle michel david pour
commenter les propos de françois
blanchet où il dit notamment que la
seule institution qui parle au nom des
québécois c'est le parlement à québec la
question qui me vient à l'esprit
dans le fond lui aussi dans un parlement
est ce qu'il ne déligitimer ce poisson
rôle à savoir exemple en disant ça va ça
peut sembler comme ça mais écoutez c'est
un éternel des bosses à ce que les gens
qui sont à la chambre des communes ne
sont louis ou non des représentants du
québec parce qu'ils siègent à ottawa
c'est pas nouveau ce qu'on attend là et
je suis pas surpris que monsieur
blanchet disent que la seule institution
qui parle au nom du québec c'est le mec
qu'a convoyeurs des députés à ottawa
la réalité c'est que ces gens là ont
beaucoup de poids et utilise une grande
partie du budget alors c'est un peu
oisifs je trouve comme
comme argumentation
ceci étant dit oui monsieur monsieur
blanchet oui lui c'est clair se fait le
porte parole de l'assemblée nationale
mais
effectivement je ne nie pas la
légitimité de monsieur trudeau et des
autres députés fédéralistes qui sont
élus à la chambre des communes alors
justement aux côtés monsieur trudeau on
va voir si revient sur les changes qu'il
avait avec lui c'est bien sur les côtés
je vous reviens
l'affirmation du rapport sur le fait que
le canada était responsable de génocide
quant aux autochtones et pensez vous que
c'est toujours le cas et sinon qu'est-ce
qui a changé depuis le rapport sur les
femmes et les filles assassinées réponse
je me suis rendu à la première nation
cobas afin de faire le deuil avec cette
nation sur les sépultures anonyme de
leurs enfants
nous avions si
gravement maltraité comme payer et qu'on
avait arrachés à leur famille depuis des
décennies depuis des générations
entières nous avons également franchi
une étape importante et concrètes à
savoir de
enlever les enfants risquent des
services sociaux profession et de les
laisser dans leur communauté dans leur
langue et leur culture et ce sont de
telles décisions concrètes
qui ne représente pas uniquement un
deuil sur le passé mais
concrétise une volonté d'aller de
l'avant et c'est cela qui change tout
question monsieur trudeau votre rival
conservateur vient de rappeler que sa
plateforme avec les chiffres
j'aimerais vous entendre et dessus mais
aussi
avez vous un commentaire
sur l'annulation du programme de
garderies que vous aviez négocier
réponse
j'ai c'est que le fait que les
conservateurs non chiffré leurs
programmes que quelques minutes avant un
débat national
vous montre à quel point ils ont
embarrassé quant à leurs chiffres car ce
qu'on les voit c'est que malgré ce
monsieur o'toole a claironné depuis
combien de semaines déjà en fait il ne
livre pas du tout
sur les besoins des canadiens sa
décision de déchirer 30 milliards de ses
investissements pour les garderies 250
mille places en garderie à 10 dollars
par jour pour les familles qui ne pas
uniquement un programme social qui m'ont
pris famille les enfants mais également
un moteur essentiel de la croissance
économique dont nous aurons besoin et à
mesure que nous reprenons des vigueur
après la pandémie ça prouve qu'il n'est
pas là que les transferts ont voté dont
les canadiens ont besoin maintenant à la
sortie la pandémie sont vraiment
concret que dans sept ou huit heures
nous aurons tellement plus à dire sur la
leadership fait bizarre de monsieur
o'toole et ce plan de l'avenir dans ce
soi-disant budget chiffré dans les jours
à venir mais je pense qu'il keynésien
constater qu'encore une fois il fait
semblant d'être le genre de leader dont
les canadiens ont besoin mais quand on
vend un peu en détail et ton copain ce à
quoi il s'engage quelles sont ses
promesses réelles on voit qu'ils
n'essaient qu'une chose c'est de vous
induire un erreur vous les canadiens
bonjour merci
la seule raison pour laquelle j'ai le
droit de poser qu'est sens parce
qu'aujourd'hui le tribunal fédéral a
décidé
que le gouvernement ne peut décider qui
est un journaliste qui n'est pas une
journaliste et
est ce que vous avez toujours sûr
votre position et pourquoi réponse
premièrement
l'accréditation des journalistes c'est
la galerie la presse et le consortium
des réseaux qui ont des perspectives
assez claire sur la qualité
journalistique et les informations
importantes qu'ils partagent avec les
canadiens et les canadiennes la réalité
c'est que des organisations
telles que la vôtre qui continue de
désinformer les canadiens et les
canadiennes sur la science autour des
vaccins sort commun nous allons
traverser cette 4ème vague et solidaire
et protéger nos enfants
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
nous voyons
des
explosions de colère et et compréhension
des faits de base la science et
franchement je votre groupe je ne vous
appelle même pas un média votre groupe
d'individus doivent vraiment assumer une
responsabilité pour la polarisation
convoi au canada à laquelle on assiste
les canadiens commencent à comprendre
qu'il y a vraiment une décision
importante à prendre quel est le pays
que nous voulons voir que nous voulons
façonner et je salue tous les
journalistes sérieux qui met les faits
au coeur de leur mission et me pose des
questions difficiles jour après jour
mais assurez-vous qu'ils soient éduqués
afin d'informer les canadiens à partir
d'une grande panoplie de perspectives
mais c'est la dernière chose que vous
faites vous mêmes questions
l'association qui représente lire
fournisseurs d'internet on dit que les
bureaux n'ont pas respecté leurs
engagements sur l'abordabilité et il y
aurait eu un mouvement pour renverser la
décision du crtc
qu'en est il répond c'est l'engagement
consent-il à quelques années face au
canadien c'était que nous allions voir
les frais de services sans fil des nuits
de 25%
il ya eu des diminutions environs de ce
chiffre mais nous allons regarder de
très près pour s'assurer qu'en fait les
coûts du sans fil
sont à la baisse car l'alternative on a
été très clair à cet égard avec les
entreprises de télécoms ducasse on sait
que si elles ne font pas baisser les
prix plus nous allons certainement
invités plus de compétitions pour que la
compétition puisse faire baisser les
prix donc il en revient ou qu'elle est
comme de le faire nous allons procéder
contrairement à leur volonté c'est à
dire éviter plus de compétiteurs
question vous avez été pendant les
débats
que ce sont les experts qui vont prendre
des décisions sur les émissions mais
vous avez aussi
dit que les émissions ont augmenté en
fait la production gazière est pas très
argumentée de tout près de 10% depuis
votre venue au pouvoir alors lequel
plafonnement parlez vous mais ce
thriller réponse nous avons voulu des
émissions
sur quelques années maintenant
arrêter ou tour du 190 mégatonnes par
année depuis quelques années avec la fin
de la pandémie et le prix du pétrole qui
augmente nous avons vu peu d'ambition
d'un secteur pétrolier gazier de
commencer à ouvrir les robinets à
nouveau et elle est un peu plus vite
mais nous savons fort bien que c'est
tout à fait contraire
une société carboneutre d'ici quelques
décennies et c'est essentiel que nous
visions cela donc le fait que la plupart
des grands producteurs se sont déjà
engagés 2
nous faire passer à la carboneutralité
d'ici 2050 nous donne cette capacité de
compréhension que nous pouvons donc
exigé qu'ils aient de vrais plans pour
atteindre ce seuil et en première offre
est il donc il faut commencer par le
fait qu'il n'y aura pas d'augmentation
et nous allons travailler avec l'auteur
comité consultatif sur la
carboneutralité pour avoir des
indicateurs clés sur 50 pour qu'on
puisse avoir une diminution qui est en
conformité avec la carboneutralité 2050
nous sommes le seul parti avec un plein
sérieux et ambitieux pour combattre le
réchauffement planétaire on a vu ce soir
qu' il y a beaucoup de belles paroles
n'est ce pas qui flotte dans les terres
mais bien peu de détails concrets sur
les modalités car seuils de travail
difficiles vous l'avez vu depuis
quelques années ce pas
parce que nous voulons être à 36% en
dessin décès de 2005 et c'est plus que
les cellules mesure un peu rappelez-vous
nous allons continuer de faire le
nécessaire pour combattre le
réchauffement avec toutes les peaux
ventes qui sont à notre disposition tout
temps bien sûr imaginant une économie
verte et des emplois verts
oui mais elle nous vient de raymond
clients tv à un but la parole
il reprit bon sens surtout j'aimerais
revenir sur votre échange avec le sud
blanche et ce soir au sujet de
l'identité son point quotidien
conférence de presse à l'heure c'est que
l'assemblée nationale est le seul par le
maquis qui parle pour le québec et que
le parlement fédéral
consulat et vous en particulier ford est
souvent des positions qui vont à
l'encontre de ce que la famille
nationale décide pour y ériger comme ça
on est soixante dix huit députés du
québec élu pour siéger au parlement du
canada de ses soixante huit députés
on est en hausse à s'asseoir autour de
la table du conseil des ministres pour
le canada entier on demeure des fier
québécois il cette insinuation cette
prétention de monsieur blanche est que
si on ne croit pas à l'indépendance on
n'est pas un vrai québécois si on passe
tous nos temps à écouter exactement tout
ce que dit l'assemblée nationale on
n'est pas un vrai québécois est tout
simplement
irresponsable
la réalité c'est que on est plusieurs
très fier québécois qui siège en à la
chambre des communes xv ont toujours
défendre nos communautés nos intérêts à
et faire notre job et l'idée que ça veut
dire qu'on n'écoute pas l'assemblée
nationale est aussi fausse parce que
j'ai démontré au cours des derniers mois
au cours des dernières années qu'on
travaille très bien
main dans la main avec le premier
ministre le go pour livrer sur internet
à travers le québec pour livrer pour
l'aérospatiale pour livrer sur les
garderies avec une entente asymétrique
qui va quand même à permettre à monsieur
legault de créer des trentaine de
milliers de nouveaux espaces pour les
québécois en garderie nous allons
travailler en partenariat pour livrer
pour les québécois c'est ce qu'on fait
depuis le début mais je comprends que
monsieur blanche est important qu'un
gouvernement fédéral soit aussi plaisant
pour répondre aux besoins des québécois
qu'on l'a été pendant cette pandémie et
comment on continue de l'être merci si
demain la dernière question alors
c'était le point de presse de monsieur
trudeau viendra
madame un ami paul dans un instant donc
on a peu de temps entre chaque chef
demande à un d'entre vous de commenter
ce qui a retenu du point de presse parce
qu'après on va revenir sur les changes
trudeau blanche et je vais aller avoue
jean christophe bouchet sur ce que vous
avez retenu
attaques contre eux une bonne news a
obtenu une injonction mais qui est un
groupe de pression qui est financé pour
se poser des politiques publiques
totalement en matière de vaccination
attaque également contre les
conservateurs qu'est ce que vous retenez
comment vous interpréter les réponses de
monsieur trudeau je trouve que dans une
large mesure monsieur tu nous avais
vingt contrôles assez importants sur le
sur les questions sur les enjeux je
trouve que on a vu ici vraiment un
premier ministre combatif j'ai vraiment
aimé sa réponse face aux rebels news
toutes les équipes de recherche qui
travaille sur la vaccination aussi
démontrer justement que ce cet organisme
la travaille ardemment à repousser les
mesures sanitaires sur le vaccin est à
toute fin pratique crée vraiment et
exacerbe la crise sanitaire dans lequel
on est et c'est bien qu'on a vraiment un
politicien qui décident de justement
prendre parti et de et de remettre les
pendules à l'heure et dans ce contexte
si je pense que ça va résonner beaucoup
chez les gens qui se sont fait vacciner
et qui veulent justement passer à autre
chose mais ça doit passer justement par
un meilleur contrôle des mesures et de
lakovic on essaie de savoir si la
commission des débats elle est allée en
appel de cette décision qui mettait en
valeur l'importance de l'absence de
conflits d'intérêts lorsqu'on est
journaliste alors on y reviendra tout à
l'heure l'on récupère la padanie paul
ii
personne ne
pourriez vous abordez
connaissent pas la critique de trudeau
des autres partis quant à lorp la
formule environnementale il laisse
entendre qu'il est le seul avec un plan
crédible pour se rendre aux 40 aux 50%
de réduction qu'il s'y fixer
vous l'avez un peu réprimandé pourriez
vous l'avouerez réponse est de nouveau
je laisse aux citoyens et aux citoyennes
de décider si sa déclaration est
crédible et franchement si c'est le cas
les citoyens devraient 7 se préoccuper
car on n'a jamais atteint nous c'est
plus jamais on est un des pires émetteur
par habitant au monde et on nous dit par
l'agencé internationale d'énergie les
nations unies l'ont confirmé le g akossi
nous a dit qu'on ne peut pas continuer
d'extraire du carburant facile et datait
de nous ces bleus même modeste donc sa
déclaration je comprends dans la dent
volet électoral c'est compréhensible
mais comme sbf mail avait dit en 2019 le
plan libéral est vouée à l'échec
de notre côté on est prêt à travailler
avec les autres partis car ce n'est pas
une question partisane et les grands
entre monsieur trudeau le reconnaissent
en fait qu'il n'a pas les idées n'a pas
le plan et
d'avoir plus de députés va me donne
beaucoup plus de chances de réussir le
dossier climatique
durant le débat c'était votre premier
débat en français oui non en fait
pendant la course à la chefferie j'ai eu
beaucoup de débats en français
oui
ça s'est relativement bien déroulée et
on vous a peut-être senti un peu timide
reculent et comparées aux autres aux
autres
chefs youtube une raison pour c'est le
resterai l'idée de l'aider base de
d'offrir une opportunité pour les
électeurs et les noms les canadiens
canadiennes de dévaluer leur choix moi
je suis là pour éduquer je suis là pour
participer mais pas pour à participer
dans des confrontations alors si je le
vois déraper un peu juge en jeu je me
laisse un peu tranquille à et je choisis
mon moment j'espère que non c'est bien
que ah si vous avez noté sa
percée
question
c'est bien
si nous devons croire les sondages vous
avez connu un déclin important depuis la
campagne 2019 et il y des personnes qui
avaient des chances d'être élus n'ont
pas de chance cette fois-ci qu'allez
vous faire pour
changer de cette façon il ne reste plus
beaucoup de temps pour
augmenter le soutien pour le parti vert
réponse eh bien écoutez j'espère avoir
pu persuader des jambes déclare qu est
ce qu on a vécu à les termes dans la
partie et comment on en a parlé dans les
médias et comme on n'a pas pu le régler
depuis avant l'élection cela fait du
tort cela c'est incontournable ce que
j'essaie de dire aux gens c'est quelle
nouvelle loi fondamentale de mal et même
et surtout nos candidats nos candidates
leur engagement envers leur communauté
envers les valeurs vertes et
certainement en verre à demi plein
concrets et des actions réelles et
progressiste alors finalement notre
système est basé sur
la fed a voté pour le député qui
représente une personne c'est vous et
nous concentrer là dessus je pense que
les gens vont trouver de vraiment une
belle réputation verte vers laquelle se
tourner
vers fille la question du g2 hammam
sousse où la boue rouge à vous la parole
le dis bah c'est une question d élite et
monsieur bernie même s'il devant vous et
le bloc dans les sondages il est absent
alors on ne pouvait même pas participé
dans notre organe de presse jusqu'à ce
que la cour fédérale il nous donne la
permission pensez vous que tout les
besoins devraient être entendus au
canada réponse écouter le son n'est pas
très bon j'ai pas tout entendu je pense
que vous avez posé la question est ce
qu'on devrait entendre votre voix je
crois qu'il faut avoir de l'espace pour
les divergences d'opinion j'estime que
notre démocratie est plus saine ni quand
il y à une divergence d'opinion ce qui
s'est passé avec le parti vert a
démontré qu'il ya des débats c'est dans
le monde politique parfois ces débats
seront difficiles si c'est votre
question alors oui moi je ne cherche
certainement pas à être
affable et les mythes l'unanimité
le parlement c'est un endroit où on
devra avoir des échanges vigoureux et
quand même trouvé un terrain d'entente
et l'indifférence entre avoir des
divergences des divergences sur les
politiques et de l'hyper partisanerie il
faut changer la culture de la politique
dans votre circonscription
c'est avec votre avenir politique si
vous n'êtes pas élu n'en toronto centre
bon je sais que c'est une question qu'on
pose à tous les chefs mais ça reste à
voir
notre campagne n'est pas encore terminé
j'avais dit que je vais passer le
majorité de montaut temps dans la
circonscription mais pas nécessairement
tout mon temps et je dois dire
sincèrement je sais que c'est nécessaire
de poser les questions mais notre parti
7ème petits partis quand on gagne une
sièges c'est toujours une nouveau siège
il faut faire le travail moi j'étais élu
à en pleine pandémie dans la deuxième
vague j'ai il y avait tant de
restrictions j'ai jamais eu
l'opportunité avons joué de vraiment
passé de temps dans le cube noté il faut
que je mérite à la con la confiance des
électeurs là mais j'espère encore de
deux âmes de voyager pour supporter à
soutenir nos candidats et candidates
ça c'est quelque chose pour le 21
septembre en fait c'est l'anniversaire
de ma soeur alors ça reste à voir mais
pour l'instant je travaille
et je peux faire beaucoup de choses au
même moment mais considéré ça c'est
quelque chose pour les 21 septembre ou
le 20 septembre micro numéro 2 souffle
un bon format mouvance armes chez le
donneur si oui
on a eu aujourd'hui le petit charles le
petit capitaux de 11 ans ce qui paraît
d'environnement oui sache que sans vos
canadiens canadiennes
capte si un jeune homme comme lui pense
déjà au futur
oui
vraiment moi mes filles sont plus +
année ag as
marie sont 17 à 21 mais sincèrement je
dis au peuple du canada je sais que
c'est compliqué je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup de technologies très technique
pour en ce qui concerne le climat mais
je crois que tout le monde a l'intuition
que quelque chose ne fonctionne pas
après des décennies de nos deux cibles
qu'on ne réussit pas à atteindre
après vraiment une record qui est le
pire parmi les g7 il ya quelque chose
qui ne fonctionne pas on ne devrait pas
laisser notre avenir dont les maires de
l'est même partie les mêmes partis qui
auront omis dans se place cette
situation alors pour ça je dis chaque
d'heures chaque verre qui a qui seraient
là dans le prochain parlement comme
député est une voix sincère pour pour le
climat mais on ne peut pas le faire seul
il faut avoir tous les partis qui met à
côté les questions partisans pour
travailler ensemble parce qu'on voit
c'est comme ça dans l'union européen
cède 1 sec 7 pays qui travaillent
ensemble pour créer un plan ambitieux il
faut le faire ici et pour charge de
charles va dire à tes parents les autres
électeurs de la circonscription que vous
vous
vous vous attend que il fait le bon
choix hamdi ci a le 20 septembre
merci
question vous avez parlé des garderies
comme un dossier des femmes est ce que
cette façon de voir est une raison pour
laquelle ses parrains vu comme une
priorité pour vous réponse oui et je
dirais cela aussi sur bien d'autres
enjeux j'estime réellement que le mans
de femmes en politique dans les hauts
échelons 1 on n'est pas sur les
priorités on a vu tout au long la
pandémie que les femmes ont les ont été
vraiment les avantages y je pense par
exemple aux soins de longue durée c'est
une question de femmes s'étaler fin du
tri mouraient dans les soins de longue
durée 7 et les femmes qui s'occupait des
autres femmes dans ces centres
hospitaliers de soins longue durée et
soins quand des femmes sont là et bières
donne moins de priorité cela donc en jeu
par la diversité dans le monde la
politique voilà ce que je veux dire que
la changerait lit les enjeux l'urgence
que nous vivons et sur laquelle nous
agissons et cela pourrait vraiment aussi
touché bien d'autres thématiques où il
lia manque de représentation des gens
qui sont le plus touchés par une
discussion nationale merci
oui elle donne rendez-vous à demain
celle des bas en laine sont là également
pour couvrir ce débat en anglais demain
dans deux minutes le chef du npd va
prendre la parole tangage mais je
m'adresse à vous parce que on peut se
demander si madame paul
a pu persuader des gens d'aller vers le
parti vert avec ce débat qu'en pensez
vous parce que son parti connaît une
baisse quand même marqué dans les
intentions de vote la tâche était
immense ce soir et je ne sais pas s'il a
vraiment réussi à faire passer son
message elle avoue qu'elle voulait aller
retirer un petit peu quand c'était trop
déraper elle dit mais
je dirais que qu'est-ce que c'est ce que
vient de dire la hausse sujet de censeur
si elle perd dans sa circonscription à
toronto cendres est vraiment ça nous dit
quelque chose or elle aussi elle admet
que le languit mentation les internes
les arguments interne au parti
le nuit et puis elle aussi sans doute
parce qu'elle va réussir alors ça vous
en dit beaucoup
on espère surtout lorsqu'elle dit que
gagner une seule circonscription sait
déjà
grande une grande victoire elle a fait
un plaidoyer notamment pour les
garderies que c'est pas seulement une
question qui touche les femmes monsieur
jack meeting sans dec en fait que les
garderies c'est un drame questions de
société on écoute me sucer
nous allons débuter avec les questions
avec les micros numéro 2 messieurs si
vous voulez y est on sûr mais ces cyclos
de loups bâti sans tambour ni trompette
les canada agit au plan international en
bilatéral et multilatéral et notamment
les plique parmi les plus grands cadres
des d'action du canada c'est la
francophonie jusqu'à sonder sentez-vous
vraiment à l'aise dans cet espace
du point de vue leadership actuel et de
l'organisation de cet espace et
lorsqu'un autre les départs des madame
catherine des canaux il ya une année
comment vous vous sentez dans cet espace
francophone ça c'est la première
question et je voudrais savoir parce que
la francophonie c'est puisse l'afrique
70 % l'afrique et le canada prévoit ce
qu'on appelle la démocratie la promotion
de la démocratie et l'aide au
développement lorsqu'on parle la
promotion de la démocratie actuellement
comment vous vous sentez du moment où
ans en l'espace de cinq points des coups
d'état ou des départs par la violence
nous notons les cales des heats derby au
tchad est gênant d des suivre in app at
il ya trois jours exactement les coups
d'état en guinée
comment vous pensez être êtes vous prêt
à revoir votre copie en matière de
coopération avec l'afrique notamment en
ce qui concerne la démocratie et plus
particulièrement avec la république
démocratique du congo et parce que
lorsqu'on lit tous et qui sait tous ce
qu'est la junte a donné comme message
que ça soit rocade
est ce que vous pensez que
les canada ne doit pas revoir sa copie
en matière de la diplomatie avec
l'afrique merci beaucoup
merci pour votre question et votre
passion a aussi qu'il ya des enjeux
tellement sérieux en afrique et le rôle
du canada dans le monde entier doit être
heureux de diplomatie promouvant le pays
pour me voir le bien être de tout le
monde on a une responsabilité à jouer
donc une rôle plus sérieux à travers le
monde pour aider les autres et pis pour
aider les démocraties c'est vraiment
important et je puis énormément sept
principes et les néo-démocrates appuient
cette idée
monsieur singh au soir louisbourg
edwards a longtemps il ya une question
qui vous a été posée pendant le débat
sur l'oléoduc trans menteuse vous n'y
avez pas répondu je vous la repose quand
allez vous coupez le flot du pipeline
trans manten la supplication donc
premiers mois je veux dire encore je
suis j'étais toujours contre 7 projets
j'étais contre l'achat de cette pipe
line j'ai dit que monsieur trudeau a
fait une erreur en faisant ça et j'étais
toujours contre ce projet
donc quand on est au pouvoir on va
analyser la situation et prendre de
décisions qui pourtant pauvres les
canadiens et canadiennes
numéro deux sur le
alexandra pour venus historiquement le
npd s'est opposé aux grandes sociétés
pharmaceutiques et où société milliards
d'un se sont enrichis grâce aux blocages
comme amazon et one là et le npd était
très attentif aux libertés civiles y
compris en état pro-choix son propre
corps pourquoi avez vous embrasser les
milliardaires de big pharma et
abandonnez votre fils et de filles de
pro choix
merci mais je ne réponds pas aux
questions des réponses merci est-ce que
vous pensez que si une option de ne pas
répondre à un média juste parce que le
fait que vous nous aimez pas nous devons
beaucoup prochaine question pour
téléphones suprême
et a fui la question du biais de quatre
heures contre 11 qui forme des blues à
vous la parole
avant de me dire que vous n'allez pas
répondre à la question j'aimerais dire
que je ne représente pas une entreprise
et vous et vous représentez une nounou
de quinzaine qui ont des questions comme
si ce n est que ma collègue vient de
poser des gens qui a vomi à marginaliser
est ce que votre message c'est que ce
sont des citoyens de seconde classe
réponse non pas du tout désolé
question
où les controverses ce soir c'était sur
les cibles de réduction de gaz
carbonique de monsieur trudeau
mais surtout la dire que c'était son
plan qui était le seul réel quelle votre
étaient trop faibles n'allait pas trop
loin
votre plateforme n'a pas beaucoup de
détails il faut le concéder comment
allez vous rendre à 40o 45% de réduction
que vous mentionnez réponse moi j'aurais
clairement que notre plan et audacieuse
et fort les gens sont convaincus qu'il
faut faire davantage
plus tôt aujourd'hui on a parlé
de cet enfant chan qui se prêtent pas 12
ans de ses enfants à venir aulas
convient des enfants qui sont préoccupés
par la planète des gens qui se
désespèrent de nous car ils ont vu
l'impact dans nos villes aujourd'hui
deux réchauffement planétaire moi je
veux investir dans les énergies
renouvelables
l'électrification des transports en
commun et on a vu la photo de monsieur
trudeau il dit ce qu'il voudra dire mais
sa feuille de route est claire il a
manqué chacune des cibles c'est la pire
feuille de route du g7 il a augmenté ses
subventions après avoir promis de les
éliminer c'est un échec lamentable mais
moi ça me désole quand je veux gagner ce
combat et je sais que nous pouvons le
gagner
les francos presse on sait qu'au canada
la cible en immigration francophones
hors québec est établi à 4,4 pour cent
depuis plusieurs années mais elle n'a
jamais été atteinte quelle est la
position de votre parti quelle serait la
cible et de quelle façon vous pensez
pouvoir atteindre une cible en
immigration francophones hors québec
merci de location j'appuie l'imposte
l'importance d'avoir l'immigration des
francophones et aussi des gens en
général je suis ouvert à travailler
ensemble avec les experts pour atteindre
un bon cible est pour moi le but c'est
d'avoir un pays qui respire la réalité
d'un pays bilingue ça veut dire
encourager l'émigration francophones ou
si accueillir les gens travers répit qui
peuvent contribuer à notre société aussi
aider dans les cas où on a des tragédies
des droits de la personne comme ce qu'on
a vu en afghanistan on a un rôle à jouer
pour accueillir les migrants et aussi on
a besoin des immigrants
gens apprennent qu'elles sont téléphone
opérateurs est fille en question
il n'y a pas de quelle photo les folles
micro numéro un soufflé bonjour monsieur
singh catherine lévesque la presse
canadienne comment réagissez vous au
fait que le plan libéral en
environnement reçoit des meilleures
notes de la part des experts de votre
plat je n'accepte pas qu'ils ont une
bons plans et on a eu une plan audacieux
avec des cibles audacieux avec des idées
inspirantes et avec une volonté et la
réalité c'est on a déjà vu le bilan de
monsieur trudeau c'était un échec
malheureusement parce que j'ai voulu
qu'on gagne je veux encore qu'on gagne
cette bataille contre la crise
climatique mais le bilan de monsieur
trudeau est un échec et lavier six ans
pour faire quelque chose il a manqué
chaque cible donc comment les gens
peuvent croire aux propos de monsieur
trudeau quand on a vu son bilan depuis
six ans c'était un chèque site inside et
si pourquoi légion mérite mieux on ne
peut pas se permettre un qui attend de
plus monsieur trudeau avec les belles
paroles pas d'action
numéro d'on
ne sait ni un peu plus tôt cette année
lors d'une veillée pour une famille
musulmane l'assassinât alain thériault
avait voulu plus de réglementation sur
les narines comme je l'avais ya déjà un
seuil très élevé sur ce qui représente
des paroles haineuses dans l'assemblée
que pourriez-vous faire pour
circonscrire la ventrèche de la liberté
de parole par exemple pour protéger les
minorités réponse nous avons des lois
c'est vrai sur le discours haineux et
pour une très bonne raison nous ne veut
pas accepter que les gens puissent faire
la promotion de la haine contre
quelqu'un la violence quand quelqu'un
pour qui ils sont ce n'est pas permis et
une femme tout à fait en faveur que ces
lois existent mais on ne les appelez pas
très bien au quotidien on voit beaucoup
de crimes haineux qui ne sont pas
poursuivis comme des crimes haineux et
c'est important de le faire
car les gens sont ciblés en lien avec
leur origine la couleur de leur peau ou
leurs racines c'est quelque chose que
haineux et on doit le dénoncer et de
façon particulière
c'est pourquoi on veut que ces lois
soient davantage appliquées maintenant
quand il est question de la peine mais
le gouvernement libéral a reconnu qu' un
problème mais ils n'ont pas agi en six
ans ils n'ont rien fait pour s'attaquer
à la parole et nous en ligne et sans
réaction du parlement on le laisse entre
lumesse des géants du web ou des médias
sociaux ils n'ont pas vraiment la
volonté de s'attaquer à na n en ligne et
lui permettent la propagation et c'est
pourquoi je crois que c'est les
responsables du gouvernement monsieur
trudeau avec son la proche de laisser
faire cela a mené à la radicalisation on
a vu que parmi les pires massacres au
canada était le résultat des gens qui
ont des radicalités par la haine en
ligne étant donné que c'est un fait nous
devons réagir en ayant la possibilité de
supprimer cette information sur le champ
celle qui s est à la haine et agir
rapidement pour arrêter cette pandémie
de haine en ligne
alors c'était les cinq points de presse
des chefs le dernier allait c'était
monsieur jack médecine qui a répondu à
plusieurs questions mais ne répond pas
aux questions de ruben news alors on va
clarifier ça un rapidement parce qu'une
somme de des voix dans le débat puis
j'ai d'abord lancé la question à mes
invités journalistes tant d'arbres news
a obtenu une injonction aujourd'hui de
la cour fédérale de terre neuve labrador
pour être accrédités
la commission invoque l conflit
d'intérêt de cette organisation qui se
fait financer pour se poser des
politiques publiques alors point de vue
de journalistes de votre part peut-être
ensuite michel là dessus est ce qu'ils
ont fait dérailler les points de presse
est ce que monsieur justin raison de ne
pas répondre à nos questions je trouve
assez de raisons de les dénoncer comme
propre agent de la dea motivation mais
si le trou d'eau à lens et une balle
contre globo news mais je veux le
corriger sur ce point si c'est que ce
n'est pas la tribune la presse ni la
consortium qui décide qui est
journaliste pour être accrédités celle
de la commission des débats de sion qui
est indépendant alors là oui gabonews à